foreign
hey everyone this is Manish from Simply
learn and welcome to this video on email
marketing full course in this whole
course we will learn all about one of
the most trendy Technologies today that
is email marketing we'll begin this full
course video with what email marketing
is and how to set up email marketing the
benefits of it and a b testing after
this we look into the different types of
email campaigns and how to engage New
users with your emails along with a
Hands-On demo using the MailChimp tool
we will then conclude this video by
discussing the essential interview
questions and answers to help every
individual crack an interview by the end
of this video I can assure you that all
your email marketing correlated queries
would have been answered
for this training with me I have a
experienced email marketing specialist
Rob and Rahul together we will take you
through the various topics of email
marketing so let's start with an
exciting video on email marketing but
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the Bell
icon to never miss an update from Simply
learn
welcome everyone this is Rob Sanders
with simply learn and welcome today
we're going to talk about email
marketing tutorial so buckle up and
let's get started with email marketing
tutorial and so let's start out asking
the question why email marketing so
Linda is the owner of an e-commerce
company and basically she isn't able to
take her leads the lead she's collecting
per day per month and convert them into
customers okay so customers sign up but
they don't buy her product so she's left
scratching her head wondering what to do
so how's she going to solve the problem
of converting the lead she gets into
paying customers well look no further
than email market so you can boost your
sales funnel with the help of email
marketing so email marketing leads to
email campaigns that lead to website
visits that can lead to product
purchasing email markings also in a it's
a very good way to generate a high
return on investment so Linda thinks
this is too good to be true you're
telling me is a very efficient way to
generate a return on my investment how
expensive is email marketing well email
marketing is neither expensive or time
consuming that's the beauty of email
marketing and so Linda is now very
interested we've piqued her interest she
wants us to explain email marketing to
her in detail and that's exactly what
we're going to do buckle up and let's
get started and talk about what is email
marketing so as I mentioned to Linda
it's an efficient way to convert leads
into sales why because we can send
personalized emails to a specific
audience a targeted audience if
somebody's interested in our product we
can reach out to them via email it can
also be used to remarket pre-qualified
leads so anybody who's pre-qualified we
can go ahead and communicate with them
as well so email marketing is a very
effective at different stages in the
funnel okay so when I say funnel
customer life cycle so we have awareness
consideration purchase retention and
advocacy okay so let's talk about each
one of these parts of the final or
customer life cycle if you will so let's
start with awareness at the very top so
email marketing allows customers to
recognize their problems after which you
can educate them on how your brand can
solve them okay just like any other
marketing channel somebody's looking for
something in need of something we can
come to the rescue in this case we're
going to come to the rescue with email
and we can go ahead and educate them on
on what their need is and how we can
collaborate with them help them educate
them solve their problems with our
product okay so that's what email is
going to do we're going to communicate
with them via email and we're going to
bring awareness to the problem by
solving the problem that's what email is
good for okay good for generating
awareness for our brand for example we
can share a newsletter with our
customers so we're running a Cosmetics
company we can basically educate them on
the five important skin care products
that everyone should have okay so we can
get them to click on the call to action
to learn more so if somebody's having
some skin care issues or not sure what
products to buy you know an email can
cover that okay the next step in the
customer life cycle is consideration so
customers focused on searching for
Relevant products and compares the
products with similar ones okay so
they're definitely looking they're a
little further in the process they're
educated they know they're looking for
so we can really hit them with the right
email we can send a relevant email to
promote our product okay discover that
perfect moisturizer for your skin
perfect skin moisturizer Smooths
hydrates and contains SPF 20. so we got
the perfect product for that person
who's further along the funnel and
really is ready to purchase that product
so we can hit that person up with the
perfect messaging let's talk about
purchase the next step in the life cycle
well purchase well with purchase we can
send an email that encourages that
customer purchase our product by
offering them something okay by giving
an offer for example we can give a
discount discounts always tend to work
so that moisturizer that that particular
customer was considering buying well
they can move from consideration to
purchasing because we're going to offer
them a discount they can't refuse okay
so you know it could beat Force specific
day okay it could be you know something
that's going to get them excited to buy
the product 20 off a moisturizer is
pretty good deal and especially if that
percentage off is better than the other
products they were considering buying so
getting somebody that extra incentive to
purchase the product goes a long way via
email okay we want to take that next
step in the life cycle and nurture our
relationship with customers to ensure
they're loyal okay if they've already
purchased how do we get them purchased
again that's retention we want to retain
our customers we want to get them back
to buy the same product or similar
products or completely different
products in their inventory so what do
we do we're going to send an email we're
going to see an email to active
customers okay we're gonna give them an
offer just for them exclusively just for
them in this example we're gonna give
them a combo pack a facial kit at just
39 and get a sunscreen worth 10 ten
dollars for free so you can come up with
all sorts of different combinations on
offers he is the offers exclusively just
for those who you want to Target and
retain as customers because if you just
get somebody to purchase once it's not
going to work those people have already
taken the that step in the relationship
where they trust your product they
purchase your product now you want to go
ahead and treat that customer special by
giving them an exclusive offer then what
we want to do is advocacy last step in
that customer lifestyle we want to
convert that active customer into brand
Advocates okay we want that customer to
talk about our brand for us we want them
to promote it and talk about it with
your friends so for example we want to
send an email to those customers to
promote our products okay so for example
we could say hey the sales of our
products for this particular day or for
this month is going to go to our
favorite nonprofit could be educating
poor children or cleaning up plastic in
the ocean or saving animals we want to
be able to get them to speak on our
behalf and say look guys this is a
really good company you know they're
offering me products exclusively they've
offered me discounts in the past they
have good products they have a lot of
different products and on top of all
that they help they help the environment
they help the needy okay they care and
so we can go ahead and provide a call to
action for these customers that are
loyal to our brand and have them share
the email with their friends to spread
the word on you know what we're trying
to accomplish for our non-profit or if
anything just get them to promote it
maybe give them a discount for every
friend that they get to buy our product
okay it doesn't have to necessarily be
you know just sharing with Friends it
can be that extra incentive of giving
them a discount if they do share with
friends and their friends Buy Okay so so
this is the customer life cycle and
examples of different emails that you
can use at every step along the way in
the life cycle so let's talk about email
marketing set up so email marketing set
up we have a series of steps that we
need to go through in order to get our
email set up to go ahead and send out to
our target audience and that first step
is we want to identify that target
audience and create segments so if
you've taken some of my and listened to
some of my webinars in the past about
Google analytics about Google ads we
talk about segmenting so it's about
targeting a specific audience that's
what segmenting is taking a piece of the
whole so we don't want to email all
users on our list all customers maybe we
want to Target a specific segment okay
so we want to be able to identify that
segment who is that segment is it
somebody who or a group of people or you
know a partial list of our customers who
purchase a specific product I would say
so versus say our entire list of
customers because our entire list of
customers can purchase a number of
different products and so by targeting a
specific segment of our audience or our
customer base we can hone in on the
message so if they all have something in
common like they all bought that
moisturizer then we can go ahead and be
specific with our messaging then we want
to create campaigns and set an
appropriate call to action okay so what
is it that we want to say to these these
people this segment of users then once
you create that campaign and and set up
the messaging and call to action we want
to test the email before we actually
click Send this is a very important step
test that email before we send and then
when we send the campaigns immediately
or we can schedule a time so my advice
here is always schedule a time you want
to be able to figure out the best time
to send that email and then once the
email's sent whenever that is you want
to be able to analyze performance and
there are some key metrics that you want
to hone in on when we talk about email
marketing and some of those are open
rates click-through rates okay response
rate okay so we want to be able to hone
in on certain key metrics when it comes
to emails so here's what we need to do
create our list add contacts to our list
create our campaign okay we want to
select the list choose a format modify
the template and then send the email
campaign so these are some basic
checklists that you want to do so let me
give you an example and go to MailChimp
so if I'm in MailChimp basically I'm
going to create a campaign okay so it's
an email that I'm going to work with and
you can see with MailChimp I have some
some examples Here regular automated
plain text or a B test I want to do a
regular email hey I'm just going to call
it test and I'm going to click begin
okay so we want to add our recipients
who are we going to add so we're going
to choose our audience okay
so we're just going to choose a sample
test for now okay we can personalize the
to field if we want okay so what do we
want to do we want to call people by
their first name their last name their
first and last name where we can
customize it just go with first name to
keep it a little bit personal okay then
we have the subject line here so it's
all about messaging right so whoever
we're targeting we want to be able to
add a message so we're just going to say
and and subject line is very key here so
you want to have a subject line that's
really going to resonate with your
audience so whoever that segment
audience is we want to make sure that
the subject line is going to resonate
with them with them so that they can
open up that email okay so uh we'll just
say having a good day we can make it
better
just as an example something that's
going to be attention grabbing if you
will okay you can always tweak the
subject line in fact my advice is always
do a b testing on the subject line so
you can do two different subject lines
with one email to figure out which one
has better open rates and then with
MailChimp we can go ahead and design the
content of our email so we're going to
click design email okay we can select a
template we have some save templates
already okay or we can go with a theme
so MailChimp has a lot of good offers
now there's a lot of different email
platforms out there I particularly like
MailChimp because of this very feature
they have a lot of good themes here a
lot of different layouts that you can
use okay so you know we're going to
Showcase that product
okay and that's the template we're going
to use here so here we go we're going to
showcase our product we're going to add
that photo of our product here and we're
going to go ahead and put some nice
messaging in here with some nice call to
action we can put our logo up here for
Branding again we can edit the content
here so based on that segmented list in
this example for Linda's company maybe
she wants to Target those folks who
bought her moisturizer before her face
moisturizer and she wants to retarget
them she wants to go ahead and say hey
you guys have bought my product before
check out this new face moisturizer that
we have to offer so whatever the case is
you want to be able to plan that out
ahead of time you want to be able to
plan out who your audience is you want
to plan out your messaging and you want
to go ahead and set up the messaging
based on that audience so once you have
the message in place voila you're more
less ready to go okay so once you get
the content all set up
you could schedule that campaign okay
and you can also add a social post to
your campaign so we can share that
information on social so email
integrates nicely with social media so
again that's that's pretty much what you
need to do here you need to really think
about who it is you want to Target
choose those recipients okay customize
it and make it personal create a good
subject line in fact create two subject
lines and then align that content with
that audience okay that's that's really
the checklist here so again we look at
this checklist creating our list who do
we want to send the email to so we added
our contacts to the list we set up the
campaign we selected the list we chose
the format we modified it with a good
subject line with some good messaging
and then we're going to schedule that
email campaign so that's the checklist
to go off of okay so remember identify
AI target audience and create segments
and you create that campaign and in our
case we did set an appropriate call to
action you know get shopping basically
we want people to shop our new
moisturizer key thing here is before we
send it out we want to test that email
once everything looks good we're going
to I would if I schedule it but you can
always send the email when you're ready
I would schedule it at the appropriate
time of day okay so in this case you
don't want to send an email out on a
Friday afternoon okay when people are
getting ready for the weekend you
certainly don't want to send an email
out over the weekend because you're not
going to have many people look and open
it and you probably don't want to send
the email out on a Monday morning when
most people are getting into the office
from a long weekend and catching up on
emails so from my experience you know
Tuesday Wednesday depending on your time
zone I would always say you know late
morning early afternoon tends to be a
good time but that's why we have
performance that's why we can analyze
performance we want to be able to see
what the open rates are and the
click-through rates are so that we can
make adjustments for future emails so
let's talk about some of those metrics
so when you do send that email you know
we're going to look at that open so open
rate is the percentage of the total
number of recipients who open an email
so okay so if we basically you know set
it to x amount of people minus those
emails that have bounced so let's just
say you know we sent it to
102 people okay for simplicity's sake
two of those emails bounced okay so that
means that we've had a 100 net 100
emails that receive the email and let's
just say 75 open the email okay we wrote
such a good subject line that they
opened it okay that's 75 that's a 75
open rate that's how you measure open
rate click through rate okay so if they
open it we hope that they click on
something and so for all of those emails
that were delivered okay in this case a
hundred how many actually did click on
our call to action so let's just say 75
opened it out of the hundred that's a 75
open rate but of the 100 that actually
were delivered let's just say we had 25
that actually clicked on the call to
action and so that's 25 okay and so you
want to be able to measure not only who
opens it but who clicks on the call to
action so that's click-through rate for
email marketing and then response rate
so it's the percentage of the total
recipients who clicked on a link of your
email campaign and actually completed
the action so in our example we're
trying to get people to click on the
shopping call to action and get them to
purchase so we set 100 emails and of the
25 who actually clicked we had 10 who
actually took action and purchase so 10
to divided by 100 is 10 so you have open
rate click-through rate and response
rate those are some key metrics for
email marketing okay the first step is
you got to get people to open it that's
where the subject line is so important
click their way that's where the
messaging and call to action is so
important we want to get people to click
on that call to action and then the
response rate we want them to buy so
those are our three key metrics related
to email marketing so let's take a look
at an example if we go back to our email
marketing platform MailChimp in this
example we're going to take a look at
some reports so most email marketing
platforms have reporting functionality
built in and so in this case what we
want to do is we want to be able to take
a look at the open Rate click-through
rates of the emails that have been sent
out previously so here we could see our
April email coupon versus tools promo
Okay so we've had basically you know
opens and click X so 14 open rate one
point four percent click-through rate
okay so the March email that went out
did a little bit better 19 open two and
a half percent on the click-through rate
so here we could see how many people
actually were sent how many opened it
and how many clicks so this is a
MailChimp makes it very easy for us to
measure you know open and click rates
and then we can measure by Revenue as
well based on the campaign so that's
measuring the response rate so it's all
built in so most email marketing
platforms have open right and clicked
rate already built into the
functionality so you can measure those
two metrics against any email so let's
talk about the benefits of email
marketing so what are some of the
benefits well we've already mentioned to
Linda that it's cost effective it's time
saving real-time marketing lesson true
of builds credibility increases
visibility and brand awareness and it's
an easy way to track Roi these are all
the benefits for email marketing we're
going to go talk about some of these now
so basically when we talk about cost
effective you know some email marketing
platforms charge based on the number of
users who you send the email to time
saving well you saw how quick it took me
to set up that email campaign the key is
figuring out who you want to send it to
when we talk about real-time marketing
you know we're sending this email out
basically in real time trying to meet
our customers needs at the right time
it's less intrusive because we can
customize the emails okay we can as you
saw I can put first name in there to
make it more personal so when
something's more personal it's less
intrusive especially if it's a segment
that already knows your brand okay
builds credibility hey we gain
credibility when we offer exclusive
offers to repeat customers or you know
try and build advocacy by working with
non-profits okay it increases visibility
and brand awareness why because you know
we could send our email out to a large
group of people and that's a good way to
generate brand awareness and as you saw
we can easily measure you know not only
open rates click rates but Roi so how
many people from that email went on and
purchased so we can measure that it's
very easy to measure email so let's move
into a b testing so a b testing is key
to email marketing so in email marketing
gaining High open rates and
click-through rates will result in more
website visitors and sales okay in
theory that's what's supposed to happen
we get more opens we get more people to
click we get more people to click we're
gonna get more people to purchase okay
but it's not as easy as it sounds so how
do we we make that possible well we're
going to do that via a b testing I've
already mentioned it when I set up my
example campaign in MailChimp I stressed
and stressed and stressed that we need
to have two subject lines go out per
email okay so before I stress that again
let me just reiterate what a b testing
is and a b testing is a method to
analyze which of the two email campaign
strategies most effective in terms of
high open rates and click rates okay so
in this case an A B test you can send
out two emails you can send out two
subject lines you can send out two call
to actions you're just really what
you're doing is you're testing one
against the other that's what a b
testing is and so in my example I talked
about that subject line so for better
results a b testing can be done with the
subject line can also be done with the
email content so the subject line
impacts the open rate okay so I wrote a
subject line I don't even know how that
subject line is going to perform but if
I write a second subject line then I'll
be able to basically give myself a
better chance of getting a better open
rate because I'm offering up two
different subject lines likewise for
email content so the subject line and
email content are the most important
elements so we want to be able to test
them if they're interesting intriguing
uh attention grabbing then it's gonna in
the case of subject lines a result in
open rates if the content itself is
interesting engaging a good offer good
call to action then the click rates are
going to be increased so we want to be
able to serve up variations for our
audience so we want to consider an
example of an A B test where Linda has
set up two variations of the email
campaign as an example so she's gonna
attend two different subject lines to
test which one generates more open rates
because that's what subject line a b
testing is going to do one of them is
going to have a I are open right okay so
in our example here Linda sends version
a of the email to fifty percent of the
recipients with the subject line three
important strategies to increase your
open rate well version B which is sent
to the other 50 percent has the subject
line three important strategies to
increase your open rate so the only
difference here is three and three the
number three spelled out well because
she sent out two different subject lines
she's going to now be able to measure
the success of that A B test okay and it
just so happens version a has a higher
open rate numbers always tend to work in
subject Lines by the way so Linda sends
version a of the email to fifty percent
of the recipients okay eighty dollars
today but ninety dollars tomorrow and
version B to the remaining fifty percent
eighty dollars today ninety dollars
tomorrow and the only really succinct
difference here is you using the word
but versus a comma and she sent that
email out and that email went out and
the data is coming in and she's going to
measure the success of that A B test
well version B has the higher open rate
you know we want to be short succinct
and stay away from those conjugations
like but okay it tends to have a
negative connotation so the shorter more
direct email or subject line eighty
dollars today 90 tomorrow not so passive
more direct and that tend to have the
higher open rate so you always want to
test those subject lines to generate
High open rates another example here
version a again gets 50 percent with the
subject line uh-oh your prescription is
expiring version B your prescription is
expiring you folks listen to this
webinar right now I wonder which one you
think will perform go ahead and put your
comments right below this video I'm
curious what version of this subject
line you would open so let's go ahead
and measure the success of the A B test
okay so she sent the email out two
different subject lines fifty percent
got one subject line the other fifty
percent got the other subject line and
it just so happens version a uh oh your
prescription is expiring there's a
little bit of a you know personalization
to that you know for me your
prescription is expiring seems to be a
little bit more you know command-ish hey
your prescriptions expiring so we expect
you to purchase where you have the
little uh-oh in front it's like hey you
know I think your prescription is
expiring maybe you should think about
renewing it okay I think that's how
that's interpreted at least that's how I
interpret it so I would probably go
ahead and click on that email with that
subject line so you could see subtle
differences in the subject lines make a
big difference in open rates so in order
to keep improving those open rates you
need to continue and not continue you
should always do subject line testing
always because one subject line is
always going to have a better open rate
than the other so always do a b testing
when it comes to subject lines and email
content for that matter okay so we're
always going to do continuous a b
testing so with continuous a b testing
we can test very various elements of the
email so you can always test the
sender's name the subject line the copy
the call to action the design the
imagery there's a lot of different
elements you can test with emails for
example sender's name okay so you want
to personalize it as much as you can
okay you don't want to do a no reply you
want it to come from a human being in
this case Sam okay at least that's what
I think let's see what the test States
no surprise version a has the higher
open rate if you cost customize these
things and personalize them then it goes
a long way sending an email from a no
reply is not a good best practice let's
talk about the subject line again uh so
we got webinar increase your email open
rights webinar increase your email open
rates so the webinar is dynamic on
version a okay so we're sending that out
and because it's Dynamic that's going to
you know beat out the static webinar
increase your email open rates a lot
more elements we can test here so for
example the email copy to learn some
easy ways to increase your email
operates join us on May 10 2019 7 PM for
an interactive discussion with our
experts well version B is more
personalized it's the same message but
we're actually addressing someone
specific in this case Rachel so we can
measure the success of the A B test but
it's not prize that anything that's
customized that comes from somebody a
name you know with a dynamic email
subject line is going to perform better
it's going to increase open rates and
it's going to increase click rates so we
can also test that call to action the
difference here is coloring save my seat
yellow versus save my seat blue again go
ahead and play along here if you're
watching this go ahead and add a comment
and just see if you're right you think
it's blue or you think it's yellow on
the call to action color does go a long
way in email marketing so let's measure
the success of this A B test and it just
so happens yellow is going to perform
better why does yellow perform better
than blue well what's more positive plus
it it kind of resonates a little bit
stronger and easier okay it stands out a
little bit better it's not as pastely
and dull as this shade of blue we're
using so you can see here we're testing
every bit of the elements of the email
anything from the from to the subject
line to the message to the call to
action and so at the end of the day you
know you want to be able to send out the
best email that's going to give you the
best results so we're going to send that
out the entirety of the email and we
could see version a looks a lot better
and why does version a look a lot better
in this example because look at the font
size is a little bit bigger version B
font size smaller harder to read that's
another thing you can test larger fonts
tend to do a little bit better now you
don't want to go overboard and have them
you know 48 points or 50 points or plus
you know 14 versus 12 goes a long way we
can continue testing we can test imagery
you can see here we have a hand aligned
with the call to action they just look
different that's all version a has one
type of hand version B has the other
type of hand Allah line with the call to
action let's go ahead and send out that
test and see what works well version B
works why the hand stands out a little
bit more clear it doesn't blend in with
the call to action so you can see we're
testing different elements here and
we're always improving and adding to
what's working so we started out with a
no reply versus somebody's name then we
move to a subject line then we move to
personalization then we move to you know
call to action then we move to an
increased font meaning the design and
then we're adding imagery so we're
constantly improving the email with each
test eventually you're going to get to a
point where you know the email is going
to be good and you're going to just
continue to test different options on it
to continue to increase open rates click
rates and response rates final output
looks like this again that personalized
email response from Sam m versus no
reply you know we got a nice Dynamic
subject line gotta personalized email to
Rachel with larger fonts okay we got a
nice call to action that stands out with
a nice image to accompany that so we've
tested all these different elements this
is the best combination based on
everything we tested so when we get that
email to go this is what it's going to
look like in the future but guess what
we're not going to stop testing so we
can continue to test those subject lines
continue to test the messaging and
continue to test the email design
continue to test different call to
actions continue to test different
images you're never going to stop
testing with email marketing okay so
let's switch over to how to optimize the
subject line subject line is such a key
component to email marketing so as we
showed you in the last segment we tested
a subject line and we used a number the
number three versus three spelled out
just so so happens that numbers tend to
do a little bit better they're shorter
easier to read and they resonate better
so including number in your subject line
you can include an emoji in your subject
line emails come a long way emojis
aren't just social media based you can
use emojis in subject lines I'd highly
recommend it you know I just signed on
an email last month with the subject
line about you know spring showers bring
May flowers and guess what emoji I had
in that subject line a flower okay may
sound cheesy but it goes a long way so
according to Experian subject lines with
emojis can increase open rates by 45
people resonate with Emojis especially
if they're positive emojis okay so we
want to personalize those subject lines
for better open rate okay when I see
personalize don't be so stale remember
that subject line we tested uh oh just
putting uh-oh in there made it sound
like we actually cared it was a little
bit personal it wasn't so personal we
weren't dressed in a specific person but
one little word goes a long way in a
subject line because when people get
emails and they read emails and a lot of
people are inundated with emails the
subject line is what they're reading
first and just by personalizing it
adding a number add an emoji I'm just
making it positive and easier to read
They're likely to open on email it's a
personalized email messages can improve
click-through rate and open rates as
well so you want to personalize your
email as much as you can whether that be
from the from field to putting that
person's name in the salutation it's a
personalized subject lines have been
found to increase open rates by up to 50
percent so don't come across as spammy
come across as you know who your
audience is and you're talking to them
and then you want to prefer title case
subject lines so title face subject
lines for example when I say title case
This Game of Thrones is my favorite show
every initial letter in that title is
capitalized okay you can go with the
sentence case Game of Thrones is my
favorite show it doesn't stand out as
much of course if you go with lowercase
it definitely doesn't stand out it looks
illiterate and somebody's probably not
going to open it so you always go with
that title case the every initial letter
gets capitalized so how to optimize that
subject line well watch the length of
your subject line you want to be
conscious of character counts so 17 to
24 characters you want to keep it short
succinct and to the point but
personalized with an emoji with initial
caps on each word to make it stand out
but you have to do that within Sony 10
17 and 24 characters so according to
campaign monitor the ideal length of a
subject line is up to 24 characters and
they're more likely to boost those email
rates okay so keep it short make it
impactful make it personalized like I
mentioned before if it gets too long
then it may get cut off and it may not
have the same impact as something
shorter so that's why we always
recommend keeping it up to about 24
characters okay if you go over by a
couple characters not the end of the
world but try and stay within that range
develop a sense of urgency okay so when
we say sense of urgency we mean sense of
urgency meaning if that coupon is going
to expire you know you want to let
people know it's going to expire that
day or the next day or within a few days
okay so you can use things like hurry up
or limit offer or Limited stock or offer
expires on okay so add a bit of sense of
urgency I mean Sky's not falling here
but if that coupon's expiring at the end
of the week you probably want to mention
something to the effect of hey offers
expiring or hurry up choose from over
300 in-demand skills and get access to
one thousand plus hours of video content
for free visit skillup by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so let's talk about optimizing your
email content so we focused a lot on
subject lines let's talk about the email
content itself so some ways to optimize
email content are we want to send the
content that is relevant to customer
expectations so content needs to match
that expectation want to use bullet
points to make the content readable we
want to follow logical structure we want
to use compelling imagery and Pro Design
emails with responsive designs and what
we mean by responsive design is hey most
people are going to be checking that
email on their mobile phone okay so make
sure when you design the email it's also
going to be good not just on desktop but
on tablet and mobile as well and then of
course goes without saying but avoid
grammatical mistakes go ahead and spell
check it and that's why we put an
emphasis on testing your email before
you actually send it and when you you
actually send an email test email don't
send it to yourself send it to
colleagues you know send it to another
group a fresh set of eyes a fresh set of
eyes that gets going to be able to pick
out that misspelled word that you
overlooked so I can't stress the sending
of the test email because it's going to
be able to you know in a way ensure that
you're doing everything on this list in
addition to grammatical mistakes you
know the person who's receiving your
test email your colleague at work may be
looking at that email on their mobile
phone and if it doesn't look good to
them they're going to let you know some
other ways to optimize email content
personalization so we did that on the a
b testing you always want to personalize
it question is hey do I use first name
do I use first and last name well guess
what you can test that but you want to
personalize it okay you want to choose
the right fonts and colors for your
email so when we were going through some
examples on testing you know I I always
tend to go a little bit larger on the
font which you could play around with it
I don't think you should probably use
white lettering on a black background
that just is not very good or best
practice but go ahead and try it if you
want okay you can always play around and
test these but you want to choose
something that's really going to
resonate with the recipient of the email
okay you want to build a rapport with
customers by sharing insights they value
for example the beginning of this
webinar we talked about advocacy we
talked about you know sharing with them
some of the non-profits that we work
with as a company okay if we have a you
know Cosmetics company and we have
different products like moisturizers and
facial creams we may want to state that
hey we don't use any animals in the
testing of these products you know we're
pro-animal we're not you know we're not
going to use animals in the testing of
our products and that probably resonates
with a lot of your customers so you want
to bet go ahead and build a rapport with
those customers by sharing those
insights and use recipient names and you
always want to personalize it then add a
clear call to action at the end you
always want to have that call to action
regardless of what the email is hey it
could be just a simple read more or hey
donate it doesn't have to always be so
hardcore in terms of hey purchase our
product that could be a turn off
especially if you're sending emails out
once a week to your customer base
they're constantly hammering them with
buy now buy now buy now they're going to
get turned off so you want to mix up the
call to actions and that goes back to
the very first step and what kind of
email are you going to send out and who
you're going to send it to so you have
to align those two if it's somebody who
doesn't even know who your brand is
you're not going to put a call to action
of buy now you're probably going to say
hey check us out we have some cool stuff
for you okay let's talk about automating
emails email automation so triggered
emails are sent to customers based on an
event date or user Behavior okay so when
we say an event could be a special
occasion like Mother's Day okay it could
be a date like a birthday or anniversary
or a specific day of the week could also
be based on user Behavior you know a
good example of user Behavior are those
who abandon the car you can trigger an
email in fact MailChimp has remarketing
functionality so with my MailChimp hey
if somebody abandons our car we can have
an email triggered and we could send an
email a nice email that says hey we
noticed you didn't finish purchasing our
product and I'm not sure what happened
but hey here's another 10 off or you can
always just make product recommendations
as well but you want to react to user
behavior and use emails to your
advantage for that so you want to take
be cognizant of different occasions you
want to be cognizant of special events
holidays cetera and user Behavior so
these types of emails can be automated
because you know when they might happen
or that they are probably going to
happen so autoresponder emails are sent
at frequent intervals based on the
behavior of subscribers so for example
if somebody purchases something then
you're gonna get an email that probably
says hey thank you for your purchase
another email that says hey your
products on its way and then another
email that says hey your package or
product has been delivered so that's an
example of an automated email that goes
out if somebody purchases your product
you probably want to thank them for that
and then you probably want to let them
know that hey it's on its way here you
could track it and then again you want
to confirm that it's been delivered but
thank them again so that's an example of
an automated email that goes out okay
let's talk about types of email
campaigns so we have different types of
email campaigns and the first is a
newsletter so with email newsletters
subscribers are connected and inform
learned about product updates so it
doesn't necessarily have to be a product
they buy it could be a product they
subscribe to like software okay you
always want to be able to send out that
newsletter to let them know what's going
on with your product are there upcoming
product updates ahead is there one that
just happened is there a webinar that
discusses the new product update so
that's what the newsletter is going to
do inform the end user about the update
so how to optimize okay so you stack
your email content create a compelling
header share different variety of useful
content like videos articles Etc with
those recipients and then follow a
consistent schedule so that's how you
handle a newsletter you should always
create a compelling header but if you're
going to send out a newsletter make sure
you support it with some good
information like a video that they can
go watch or an article that will follow
up on what you put in the email or
promoting that webinar that's going to
talk about that product product update
so example here is a newsletter that
gets sent out and here you can see it
talks about business process it's got
some nice imagery in there okay call to
action it's got a little bit of
everything in this email template okay
and that's when we talk about stack your
email content that's what you talk about
stacking you can see at the top it's got
work with the industry best subscribe
now okay they validate that with 25
years of top notch service then they
talk about hiring the best talent and
you got the next bit of content below
that so that's stocked email content
okay that's going to be supported by
compelling header and then they're going
to share a variety of different content
in there like there could be Clicks in
there to video videos and articles
moving on from newsletters to
promotional emails so we want to be able
to drive Revenue by sending special
offers through promotional email okay so
how do we optimize a promotional email
well we want to personalize the cam
campaign okay promotional we want to
definitely personalize it include time
sensitive offers we want to get people
to react okay so that means you know
adding a sense of urgency in the title
and the subject line okay you can send
offer emails on holidays if it's
Mother's Day hey send it a couple days
before or even send it on if it's
personalized then you can say hey so and
so we know you're a mother here take 20
off I mean that kind of personalized
email with an offer goes a long way here
you an example from Toms limited time
extra 20 off all styles they include the
code in there okay again you can see the
the sensitivity and the sense of urgency
with the limited time another email
campaign type and personally one of my
favorites is abandoned cart so abandoned
card emails I like working with
abandoned card emails because you know
we want people to purchase and and as
much as you try on your email marketing
campaign to drive traffic to the website
and as hard as the website works to get
people to convert through the shopping
cart it's never going to be a hundred
percent and so abandoned cart emails
give us that extra incentive to get that
person back to the shopping cart to
purchase okay so these emails are shared
with customers who have added product to
their cart but didn't finish through the
checkout process in other words they
didn't purchase the product so it's an
effective way of sales recovery it gives
us another opportunity to reach out to
that person who just is almost there but
not quite ready to finish the purchase
so what are we going to do we're going
to send out an email for those that
abandon their car and we're going to use
a simple abandoned card email template
okay you want to be simple here you
don't want to get complicated we're
trying to make this easy for them to
finish purchasing the products and we
want to definitely personalize it okay
we want to send a series of email
reminders okay in your email reminder
add a product image so as customized as
it can be it could be even the product
image of what they've abandoned and
that's the best practice so if it's that
facial moisturizer that Linda's trying
to promote and she can't quite get
enough people to finish purchasing the
product they're they're banning the cart
well she can certainly send out the
abandoned cart email okay so for example
you want to personalize it hey you
forgot to complete your order you left
something in your car can we help email
too hi there so and so items in your
shopping cart are selling out quickly
it's a gentle reminder okay so come
across a little bit different here okay
email three hey so and so 20 off on your
cart valid until so and so offer on your
favorite product so the first email that
went out and the series of emails hey
you forgot something hey is there
anything we can do to help you complete
the product purchase email two is just
that gentle reminder hey we're selling
out quickly you might want to purchase
that product and email 3 is to really
help them along by saying hey here's 20
off valid until so and so so it's just a
small series of emails that go out try
and get somebody back into the shopping
cart okay let's talk about re-engagement
campaign so in a re-engagement campaign
it's a series of emails sent to an
active email subscribers so what it does
is it boosts engagement and helps to
maintain a high inbox placement ratio
inbox placement ratio so we want to be
able to make sure that we're getting
people back on a subscriber list so how
are we going to optimize for something
like this this is now these are
difficult type of email campaigns we're
trying to re-engage with people who are
inactive so we want want gamification to
re-engage subscribers or we want to
prefer subject lines like hey we've been
missing you or did we do something wrong
okay we can run a poll or competition to
re-engage with our subscribers so for
example hey we'd hate to miss your
birthday go ahead and update your
account this is a Starbucks email so
we'd hate to miss your birthday so it's
that you know message of missing you you
can always soften or sweeten the deal
with an offer as well so that brings us
to how to engage with new subscribers so
we just talked about re-engaging with
inactive we want to talk about engaging
with new subscribers so how to engage
with new subscribers well thank your
subscribers for joining and create clear
and compelling subject lines that is a
must regardless of what type of email
you send out you always want to send out
that compelling subject line okay notice
the good examples within 17 in 24
characters know the ideal time to
message okay again sending it on the
weekend's not gonna work okay sending it
out during the weekday you know in the
morning mid morning you know sometimes
in the afternoon works really depends on
who your audience is the weekends
probably aren't going to work they avoid
the no reply Center name again
personalize it you're either Sam or Rob
or so and so Sally you know let them
know that the email is coming from a
real person okay because if it doesn't
come from a person most people aren't
going to respond okay we want to let our
subscribers know the privacy policy so
we want to let them know that we abide
by a privacy policy okay that's you know
getting you know straight with people
who are new they don't know your brand
they don't know your privacy policy they
don't want to get spammed in other words
so putting that out there makes you more
transparent and trustworthy okay and
again
personalization always personalized if
it's new if it's inactive repeat
customers loyal customers lifetime
customers you should always personalize
and you should always be courteous and
always thank them and then prefer
attractive email designs okay work with
something that's going to be eye-catchy
and then most important most important
is include an unsubscribe link I can't
tell you how annoying it is to get an
email and not have the unsubscribe link
there that makes me want to unsubscribe
even if it was a good email I still look
for that because maybe they're good
company but they're spamming me they're
sending me too many emails so maybe I
want to unsubscribe or change my
subscription so you always want to
include that unsubscribe Link in fact in
the United States it's actually law so
there is regulation about that around
that so you need to include an
unsubscribe link it's just common
courtesy if anything so it bodes well
okay of course you don't want people to
unsubscribe but you don't want them to
get annoyed either okay let's talk about
email marketing tools so we talked about
MailChimp so there are plenty of email
marketing platforms out there I use
MailChimp I've used a few in the past
like Marketo I've used Zoho vertical
response so there are a lot of different
tools out there here some of them again
MailChimp Marketo Marketo is a marketing
automation tool or system and Marketo is
good for sending those automated emails
HubSpot convertkit send in blue aweber I
mean these are just some of the many
that are out there okay so let's show a
demo again of an email marketing
campaign so let's Show an example of a
newsletter that one of my clients had
sent out and so this is Paul Ekman group
Paul Ackman Dr Ekman inspired the TV
show lie to me so well known in the
industry of micro Expressions he's the
form mentioned expert in micro
expressions and he sends out email
marketing campaigns and he sends out a
monthly newsletter so this is a
newsletter was sent out in November
2018. and if we look at it you can see
here okay it's stacked content nice
imagery okay respectful disagreements
how to deal with disagreements this
holiday season so really relevant
personalized because And Timely because
it was set in November during the
holiday season so got some nice imagery
there okay we got content in here and
then right below that on the stack
content what do we have final hour 24
hours 25
off so that sense of urgency built in to
the email and here you go you have some
other content in there based on the face
of contempt okay just an exam sample of
a micro expression and then right below
that what do we see we see a call to
action learn how to use micro
Expressions to your advantage so call to
action here then we have some more
information here with the learn more so
a newsletter that went out basically
really a blog post built into the email
with some nice content reminding folks
hey they have 24 hours got some other
useful information in the email so this
email went out very timely 98 000 okay
see subject line here controversy
respectful disagreements and
Thanksgiving okay could the subject line
be a little bit shorter yes possibly but
if we look at the open rate 15 16 open
rate okay industry average in education
and trainings 18 okay so they're close
to the industry average on the click
rate you know 1.6 percent on the click
rate industry average 2.1 so we can see
what the top top links for clicks okay
so they have a lot of links and and
MailChimp will help you measure what
links were clicked the most who
subscribed what subscriber with the most
opens we can see opens by country but
that's an example of a newsletter for
this particular company okay stock
content okay sense of urgency okay you
can see the subject line timely
newsletter so this is a a good I think a
good example of an email for the time of
year okay so let's go over the checklist
again for email marketing so good
reminders on the checklist this is a
checklist you want to make sure all
boxes are checked you want to create
interesting subject lines as they boost
your open rights direct correlation with
open rates is subject line okay you want
to keep your content relevant and
consistent with your brand you want to
check the sender name okay so you want
to make sure or not only is it
personalized but the name aligns with
the email address okay should always
personalize it always personalize the
subject line and the email copy text
meaning you know don't just say hello
say hello to Sally Pete Rob Michael
Etc always include an unsubscribe Link
in emails okay give people the option to
unsubscribe okay you can always
re-engage them another way or later on
but you don't want to irk any one of
your potential customers use a b testing
we talked about a b testing the webinar
there's lots of different elements we
can test from subject line to content to
font to call to action to imagery to
subject line Etc there's no shortage of
elements in an email you can test you
want to use welcome emails to build good
customer relationships so when somebody
signs up for a newsletter send out a
welcome news email to them hey why
welcome thank you for signing up you
should always segment your list based on
user Behavior so if you have a group of
people who purchase product a customize
your email for product a but you know
you can mention product b and c in there
but know who your audience is so you can
talk to your audience okay and you can
always ask your subscribers to update
their preferences as well because you
want to make sure you're sending out
emails to the right person right address
okay this is a a short checklist now we
can expand upon this but these are some
of the most of the key items when it
comes to email marketing some other
items on the checklist include features
such as countdown timers and live polls
okay make it interactive okay choose the
right email frequency don't be sending
emails three or four times a week once a
week is probably as much as you want to
go depending on what it is if somebody
purchases something then you probably
want to send an email thanking them for
the the purchase another one letting you
know the product has been shipped and
another one with thank you the product
has been received reward those
subscribers send out exclusive offers
okay make sure your emails are optimized
for mobile that means send out test
emails and check it on different devices
okay create a schedule okay you can
automate these emails so create a
schedule that makes the most sense have
a footer and a header in the email and
in that footer and header is going to be
some information okay just like I showed
you with the micro Expressions there was
a footer and header avoid spam filters
okay how do you avoid spam filters well
apply best practices you don't have
spammy subject lines have an actual name
associated with the reply to email and
and split up your list as well when you
send out one email to 150 000 people it
could probably get caught up in some
spam so segment out your audiences keep
your audience list short so that your
messaging can be specific to the
audience that's going to help avoid spam
and then of course you always want to
measure and analyze results so remember
a lot of these email marketing platforms
have the results built in especially
open rates and click rates we're going
to talk about MailChimp so we're going
to go through the features and benefits
of using MailChimp as your email content
platform so buckle up and let's get
started with MailChimp so the first
thing you need to do is sign up for an
account with MailChimp and that simply
just providing an email address an ID
and a password and I recommend when you
actually sign up for an account you sign
up with a free plan first and let's take
a look at what the feature plan features
are for MailChimp so I'm recommending
the free plan but when you actually sign
up you have the option to actually pay
for a plan so you have the essential the
standard the premium or the free and so
I recommend you go with the free version
first it's like buying a car you want to
test drive it out see if you like it see
if you like the features and benefits
and you can see here that with the free
plan you get a lot of features and
benefits so you get all the basics for
businesses that are just getting started
so if you're just getting started with
email marketing I would recommend the
free plan here because you have a 2 000
contact maximum so that means you can
send out an email to your 2000
recipients free of charge so not a bad
deal for businesses who are starting out
I mean if you are prepared you've used
MailChimp before then go ahead and sign
up for one of the paid versions each
version has a different set of Standards
a different set of features and benefits
from the essential all the way up to the
premium where you're going to get that
you know Advanced features
um and more customization but that's 299
dollars a month so if you're not
prepared to pay that amount then my
recommendation start with that free plan
now when you actually do set up your
account you're just gonna again provide
a ID email address and password you're
going to go through a couple of steps
and one of these steps that I would
recommend you do right away is connect
to your Facebook and Twitter accounts so
if you already have a Facebook and
Twitter account very simple all you're
doing is authorizing MailChimp to
connect to the account and the reason
for that is when you actually connect
your Twitter Facebook account you'll be
able to then you know share content on
those platforms and MailChimp will do
that for you automatically okay so here
you're just asking it to more or less
interact with the platform social
platform and I recommended doing that as
you're going through the setup process
very simple to do if you're already
logged into your Twitter Facebook
account all you need to do is click on
the plus Button as you go through the
setup Wizard and authorize MailChimp to
access your Twitter or Facebook account
here you can see what mailchimp's going
to be able to do they're going to be
able to retweets from your timeline post
tweets for you on your behalf if you
want them to if you want them to you're
going to allow MailChimp to see create
and manage your advertising data
including the campaigns and audiences
and the reason for this is you may you
know want to integrate your email
marketing efforts with your social media
efforts and the great thing about
MailChimp is hey look if you want to
post content on these platforms you'll
be able to if you want to leverage other
benefits from Facebook and Twitter and
integrate them with MailChimp you'll be
able to so having these two Platforms in
the case of Facebook and Twitter talk to
MailChimp is a positive because then
you'll be able to do a little bit more
get your message out there a little bit
more so I highly recommend you take this
as a necessary step when you're going
through the setup now it's optional you
don't have to but I recommend it now
when you're actually setting up your
account you're going to be asked to you
know design a template okay so you could
pick a template just by default you
could pick one just to get the account
going but you can always go back and add
or change out the template so here you
can see I'm in the setup wizard but I
arbitrarily just chose a template I can
go back and choose some of the templates
that are available to me now again you
can create your own template if you want
to okay so you just click create
template and you'll be you know asked to
choose kind of a you know template that
you can pretty much change and customize
so if you're thinking about sending out
an email with an announcement then
that's the type of template you want to
choose and so here now you can see we
have a logo we can change the
announcement here we can add photos
Etc so if I want to add my logo I'm just
going to go up to this top portion here
click the little pencil icon that'll
allow me to edit here you can see it's
default logo I don't really have a logo
so I can say replace it I can also link
to it and here you can see in the
content Studio MailChimp I don't have
any images to choose from so I'm going
to go ahead and upload one and I'm going
to go ahead and upload my logo that I've
had on my desktop okay so it's going to
upload and now I can select that and
insert it so now I have my logo as part
of my template here and you can also see
you can add some styling here to this
header part so I can add a nice border
around that okay so I can align It
Center I can go edge to edge okay so I
can customize the image in this
particular template here so I'm just
going to click save and close now I'm
ready to move on to the next part which
is just click on edit I want to make an
announcement okay share your big news
okay we're we're having a launch party
so here you can see again just in this
template these quote-unquote
announcement template I'm able to just
make changes to each section now I'm in
the section of the announcement part
where I can now customize the text and
you can see I can you know bold it you
know I can choose a different fonts go
Ariel I can choose the size you can make
it smaller larger pretty easy to use
like it's again style it with different
color and so I can make multiple columns
here if I want to so there's a lot you
can do just in this one section as well
so let's go ahead and just do one more
thing here let's maybe call it or
something I mean you can see I can add a
link let's go ahead and make it blue
that's the background so I want to
change the background so I'm just going
to click Ctrl Z I'll change the color of
the font itself there you go very simple
and easy to use now I can add photos
here if I want to so let's go ahead and
edit this bottom part here so I'm going
to click again the edit icon okay so
here you can see I have three images in
the template I'm going to go ahead and
add to that so here I can go ahead and
upload some files so I have some files
waiting for me on my desktop I'm just
going to go ahead and add them and
upload them to the content studio and
now that I've uploaded them I can select
one of them to insert okay now I'm going
to go here insert the second one and now
I'm going to grab the third one and
insert that in its place here you can
see now I can go ahead and you know
style each one of these if I want to
okay I can add a border again okay I can
go ahead and do rounded Corners okay
settings you can see how I can set it up
this so they're all vertical I can do
this so I have a lot of flexibility
and what I add to these particular you
know templates okay this is again just
the announcement template and so now I'm
going to click save and close
and here you can see I can add some
other things to it if I wanted to I
could play around with the design and
header and once I'm done really if I'm
happy with my email I can just close it
out and I'm done so what I could do now
is when you're done with this template
you can just preview and test it so I
could send a test email or enter preview
mode so if I enter preview mode this is
what the template I've chose is going to
look like if I happen to send it out
okay this is what it looks like on
desktop this is what it looks like a
mobile and if I go inbox preview I'll
need to upgrade my account because I'm
on the free version so but I can
certainly see what it looks like on
mobile and desktop so I'm just going to
click out of that and this is a template
and so I can go back and edit this
anytime I want so when I'm done I'm just
going to go ahead and click the
MailChimp icon in the upper left it's
going to ask me to name my template so
I'm going to name this the announcement
template I'm going to click save and now
it's in my templates so I'm free to use
this template anytime I'm ready to send
an email okay and again I can you saw
how easy it was to make a change in the
template itself so when I'm ready to use
the template I can just go ahead and
grab it okay and again I can go ahead
and style it and design it any way I
want so you have different sections of
the page that you can style and here you
got you know mobile style designs if you
wanted to now if you wanted to in the
template if I want to like duplicate the
whole block I can duplicate that whole
block and you can see it just copied it
or I can just get rid of it to very easy
to use wysiwyg if you will or interface
it allows you know MailChimp allows from
some easy you know functionality easy
features to go ahead and manipulate and
change to your liking okay so again I'm
working with a template here so anytime
I'm ready to use that template for an
email I can go in and start using it
okay and if I go to templates again I'm
going to find my template here hair I
can always edit it I can always share it
I can always preview it I can replicate
it and that's the important thing so if
I replicate it I'm basically creating a
copy of it okay so I just created a copy
so now if I wanted to create a or change
the copy of it I can do that so if I
don't like this whole block I can just
delete it and now that I'm done I can
rename this I'm just going to say
announcement template V2 so now it's
been renamed and now I have two
templates just simply by choosing one
and replicating it so again if I go back
to templates here here I go I have my
two templates and I can store these in a
folder so I'm going to add a folder I'm
going to call it announcements and I'm
going to add the folder and that's it so
now I can store these in the folder so
you can organize all your templates in
different folders if you want to so I'm
going to take these two templates here
move them to my announcements folder and
there you go there in the announcements
folder so if you're going to create
multiple templates then I would rack
recommend you go ahead and organize it
create folders you know and set up as
many folders as you want and need
because you're going to probably have
different templates for different
occasions depends on what type of email
you're sending out so I just chose
arbitrarily an announcement type email
so now if I go back to create templates
okay you can see again let's go through
some of these others again I just chose
make an announcement you can tell a
story follow-up educate you got all
sorts of different templates that you
could choose all sorts and here you got
some themes so you can even go with a
theme if you wanted to so for example if
you're selling products let's just say
you have a boutique store let's just
choose this Boutique template if I
choose this here is my themed template
and so now just like the other template
I I was working in I can go ahead and
edit this here you can see at the top I
got the middle section you know I got
all these different sections that I can
now I'll go ahead and add it so just
about really it's about choosing the
theme template that works best for you
and feel free to you know try these
different templates out and see what
works best for you so here you can add
in certain things like you know social
share so if I just drag and drop I can
add in a social share image card so a
lot of these themes are very flexible in
what you can do in terms of the design
in terms of the content so again if you
go back and I'm going to cancel and not
save this temp well let's save it we'll
call critique we may use it again in the
future so I'm going to go ahead and
click save and now it's a template it's
going to be located in templates and
again if you always want to access
templates just go to templates you'll
see the templates that you already have
created and added so you can edit them
always just by clicking the edit button
now that's again if you want to create a
new template just create click on the
create new template call to action again
you got themes you've got layouts or you
can even create your own from scratch
you can import another template that you
created in another email marketing
platform or you could do simply just do
everything from scratch in HTML so you
have three different options here
layouts themes and creating a template
on your own okay and that's either by
importing or by creating it from scratch
okay my recommendation I like some of
the layouts that MailChimp has you can
see a lot of flexibility here and when
you actually choose one again you're in
full control of how to design and
message it so you're in full control of
that so if you just want to again tell a
story I'm going to select this template
here okay now I'm on the free version so
keep in mind with the free version I
don't have access to all the templates
so here I get an upgrade to use this one
but for example if I don't see the
message upgrade to use then I'm free to
grab it so you can see the one column
I'm free to use so I'm just going to
select that and now I have this template
available to me so again I'm I'm free to
edit this one as I see fit I mean I can
go ahead and again drop in any one of
these elements that are available to me
here I'm going to drop in my social
block okay so here you can see I can now
customize my social blog if I want to
add in another platform I can do that
social media platform click save and
close so you can see they're very
customizable all of these themes and
layouts are very customizable and again
when you're done it's just a matter of
you can preview it or test it you can
enter preview mode or you can send
yourself a test email okay as if you
send yourself a test email you can
actually see how it looks when it comes
in so let's go ahead and do that here so
I'm just going to send myself a test
email and the email has been sent so
let's go check our inbox so here is the
email that I just created from the theme
you can see here all I did simply when I
edited I just dropped in my social Block
in here so this is what the email looks
like and the great thing about MailChimp
is they have an option that that you can
view the email in a browser if you can't
or you know don't want to look at it in
your in this case I'm looking at gmail
so you can always or recipients can
always view the email in a browser
versus the email client that they're
using in specific now when it comes to
completing your profile on MailChimp
you're going to need an audience to send
these emails to and so when you click on
audience here if you don't have an
audience already imported into MailChimp
you're going to be asked to import so
you can see I already have one contact
that contacts me because I added my
email address on that test email so
MailChimp smart enough to say okay we
don't have this email address and our
contact list so we're going to add them
so here we could see we can manage our
audience so we can add subscribers we
can import contacts we can have sign up
forms and we can manage our contacts so
if we import our contacts if I click on
import here I'm going to be at asked to
import either from a CSV or copy and
paste or I can just go ahead and
integrate it so if I choose for example
any one of these then it's going to pull
in the context I have there and so it's
up to you how you import your contacts
now the whole point of contacts is you
want to probably or really not probably
it's a best practice to actually create
different lists so that you can use
different audience lists with different
emails and so here you can see I have
one email address I can again import
contacts or I can add them individually
so I can ask subscribers here okay
that's another option that's the slower
option my recommendation be import them
but when you import make sure you your
importing lists that have some
commonality so you can manage those
lists so if you have one list that or
say you know clients who have never
purchased then you want to create a list
for them if you have clients who have
purchase separate those out okay so
that's the way I would good about it now
if you're trying to build a list
MailChimp has what they call signup
forms so you have different forms that
you can embed and or have as a pop-up
and when people add their email address
to that form then it's automatically
going to get added to your MailChimp
account so that's a great feature in
MailChimp that allows you to you know
build out your audience just by using
one of their forms so again we have a
subscriber pop-up you've probably seen
some of these on some of the websites
you've gone to so you can customize it
and if you want somebody to subscribe to
your newsletter for example all they
need to do is enter in their email
address and click subscribe okay that's
the the pop-up version now again you
have the opportunity to you know use
other forms as well so you got a form
Builder here or an embedded form okay or
you can integrate the form okay so if I
click form Integrations here I can use
wufu or Squarespace I can integrate with
them if I go back to sign up forms if I
choose form Builder here I have a sign
up form and then I can customize that
form with different boxes okay or Fields
okay so whatever field I want somebody
to add information to I can have that in
there and then this form could be you
know on your website so that's a great
feature about MailChimp is it helps you
build an audience so I can add this form
to my website and anybody who fills out
that form is going to be added to my
subscriber list that I can use for
future emails to take that a step
further I can even go from building a
form to building a landing page so here
you can see if I click on audience I can
go ahead at the bottom right here I have
an option to create a landing page so if
they click on that just like everything
else in MailChimp it's fairly easy to
use I'm just going to name it test click
begin here I can choose my audience
again I can what audience do I want to
add these emails to I click begin and
and I'm gonna accept and here now I have
all these different templates that I can
use as a landing page so if you want to
use these landing pages to collect
emails and those emails are going to be
added to your audience then you have a
nice selection here at your disposal
okay so here I'm just going to choose
one you know grow my list okay this is a
landing page so I can customize it just
like I do with my email template I can
add my logo okay I can start adding
different fields here like an image I
can drop an image here okay I can go
ahead and you know drop in my social
shares okay I can drop in a box a text
box okay and then I can start
customizing it with some text some
imagery you know some other information
again this is a landing page that I can
then add to my website and so anytime
somebody goes to the landing page and
fills out their email address and hit
subscribe it's going to be added to that
audience list and then I can turn around
and send an email using one of Mount
templates to that audience so MailChimp
really does a great job of allowing you
to grow your list within your own
website via a landing page a form
submission or or form or pop-up so there
are lots of different options available
to us so I'm going to click save and
close here and now this landing page is
available to me so I can customize the
URL I can edit the audience that these
emails go to I can add a page title and
again I can edit the design so I can
really make this an integrated part of
my website by designing it so it fits
the feel and look of my website I can
add a specific URL and I can add a nice
page title to it so MailChimp again does
a great job of just making it so easy
for you to build out a landing page for
you to use on your website to collect
email addresses so if you're doing a
pay-per-click campaign on Facebook or
Google you can actually Drive traffic to
these landing pages and get people able
to fill out a form submission and when
they fill out the form submission that
email address is going to get added to
your audience that's an option or you
can just add it as part of your website
and people who go there from say organic
search can find that page and add their
email address organically so that's a
great thing about the audience feature
in MailChimp and that not only can you
select an email template but you have
options to grow your audience okay again
importing contacts you can simply just
add contacts you can add you know a form
submission via pop-up a regular form
fields to your website or you can add a
landing page so it's important to note
that in MailChimp if you go to the
content Studio that's where you're going
to find all the files that you've added
to all your templates or landing pages
that you used before so if I click on
content Studio here here you can see the
files I've added to my templates if you
have products you can add your products
here okay so if you have an e-commerce
store you could certainly add your
products and then those products can be
used on your landing page or your email
templates you have something called a
giphy you can insert these into any of
your emails make it fun exciting
engaging here you have Instagram so what
you can do is you can integrate you know
any one of your Instagram accounts if
you have multiple accounts or if you
have one instagram account you can
integrate that one instagram account in
with your MailChimp account and when you
do that it's going to pull in all the
images that you've had on Instagram and
then you have an opportunity here just
to add a logo okay so you can use any of
your Instagram images within your emails
use one of these cool giffies again you
can import your products that you can
use for your email templates or just
keep tabs on all the files that you've
added before just by clicking on my
files now when you get to the point of
building different audience lists and
sending out emails you're gonna have the
option to look at reporting to see how
those those emails perform for those
specific audiences now again an audience
is a set it's like a segment you know
these are set of individuals who are
going to receive a specific email so in
this example you can see I have
different audiences and if we look at
say any one of these audience or even
just go to all audiences we'll be able
to see how we fared on some of our
emails okay so for example if I send out
an email here in April and this is April
of 2019 I could see how many total
subscribers I've had now along with the
number of subscribers you have you have
what we call open rate and click-through
rate now we explain a lot of the
reporting and the specific email metrics
and another recording that we did last
week so if you're interested in learning
more about some of the metrics then
check out the video that we have on
YouTube email marketing tutorial uh we
recorded this last week go into details
about all the different metrics you can
learn about with email marketing so take
a look at this video email marketing
tutorial it'll be a nice precursor to
the MailChimp tutorial so to give you
some insights as to what metrics to
really pay attention to with email
marketing but in MailChimp we know we
can look at the total number of
subscribers we know that we have how
many opens and we know what the open
rate is and again the total number of
clicks and what the click-through rate
is okay so with MailChimp very easily
just hover over it you get the raw
number and then the percentage so open
rate is how many people actually open
that email based on the total number of
people that the email was sent to so
here we can see in this particular email
last year in April you know we've had 14
14 1.1 percent to be exact and that is
13 377 divided by ninety seven thousand
four sixty nine so that's how many
people open the email to Third thirteen
thousand out of ninety seven is about
fourteen percent now when somebody opens
it we hope they're going to click on it
and so here we got a 1.4 click through
rate and again that's the total number
of clicks based on the total number of
subscribers or people that were sent the
email and so MailChimp just gives you a
nice overview of how many subscribers
we're in this particular audience list
and then the open rate and click rate so
we can really dive in here and we can
actually see how that particular email
performs so we just pick one email here
we can just click view report we have
other options here we can print we can
download we can share it the whole
campaign or just view the email if we
want to view what the email look like we
can select that so we just want to view
the report so we're going to click view
report and now we can get into some nice
detailed information about the actual
report itself so again here you can see
total number of recipients and this came
from the audience list called newsletter
okay it was delivered last year
September 26 2018. again I have the
option to view it download it print it
or share it so let's take a look and
view the email to see what it looked
like okay so this is what the email
looked like we have our own template
here and here you can see it takes into
account some of the best practices
involved with email marketing you know
we have some nice content imagery some
call to action here some other links
okay we have our social icons okay so
that's what the email look like okay so
we'll go back and we're going to click
view report now we want to view the
report again here's what it looked
here's when it was sent okay the open
rate for this was 21 click-through rate
was four percent so for us the list
average this list here newsletter the
average was for the open rate 16.8
percent so we're above the average on
this email for the click-through rate
the list ever is 2.7 so we're above the
average so we've done a good job on this
email at least generating more opens
more clicks and MailChimp even takes
that a step further they'll even show
you what the industry average is for
your particular industry and in this
case for Education and Training so we
did better than the industry average for
both the open rate and for the
click-through rate so we could see some
other specifics we could see the raw
numbers of opens clicks how many people
bounce meaning the email address wasn't
valid anymore and so MailChimp does a
good job of any email that actually
bounces it'll be scrubbed and removed
from your list and then here you can see
347 unsubscribe so the the thing about
you know MailChimp is we want to be
careful we don't have too many
unsubscribes and also people abusing or
reporting abuse meaning you don't want
to send out an email multiple multiple
times a week where it gets the point
where it's spammy and so you want to
avoid a high number of unsubscribes and
a high number of abuse reports and so
here you can see most emails are open
within a 24-hour period and then it kind
of just tails off so here we can see
opens and clicks based on the time of
day so within the 24 hour period okay so
this is how most emails operate within
that first 24 hours you're going to get
a lot of opens a lot of clicks and then
it's going to tell off from there great
thing is MailChimp provides me more
detailed information about what was
clicked so I could see here the top
links that were clicked and let me just
point one thing out here whether you use
MailChimp or you use any other platform
whether that be vertical response or any
other type of email marketing platform
you want to use UTM tracking with your
links so that Google analytics can pick
up the actual campaign so here you can
see we have UTM tracking appended to our
links and let me just go in to detail on
that for just a minute so MailChimp
again gives us nice data on open and
click-through rates but when we send out
an email and people actually do click on
one of these links they're going to go
to our website and from there Google
analytics is going to take over on the
tracking so this is as far as MailChimp
goes so we want to be able to bridge the
gap between MailChimp reporting and
Google analytics meaning when they came
from the email email went and went to
the site did they convert meaning did
they download something did they
purchase something and so we want to be
able to bridge the gap and UTM tracking
which is simply appending the original
URL with some tracking parameters named
UTM it allows us to bridge that Gap so
all you need to do when you set up a
MailChimp campaign is just go to URL
builder in Google then you're going to
click on campaign URL Builder and we're
going to go ahead and set up an email
campaign and so for example if we go
back here this was the original URL so
if I just copy this original URL here
and paste that as part of my website URL
what's my campaign Source I'm going to
put MailChimp what's my medium I'm going
to put email so MailChimp is the source
of where the traffic came from the
medium the means in which they arrived
at our website was via email and then
the campaign name we're just going to
put maybe whatever it is summer promo so
with the URL Builder you have five
parameters for UTM tracking you don't
have to use all five okay so here we
need to put in the URL and we need to
put in the source but the other four
parameters medium name term and content
are optional so you don't have to put
anything there but the more parameters
you put in the more specific it is for
you to track the behavior of that email
campaign so here I can see MailChimp
email summer promo and then for the
content I can use that to differentiate
my my subject line so when you send out
an email we mention this in the email
marketing tutorial you always want to
send out multiple subject lines meaning
one list gets one subject line another
list gets this a second subject line
because you want to be able to measure
open rates based on subject lines so I
can use the campaign content parameter
for different subject lines and notice
the URL Builder once I enter in my
parameters it's going to append the
original URL with a new URL appended
with UTM tracking so if I copy that I
can simply just paste that in my browser
just to see if it works and here you can
see it works the page loaded the
original URL with UTM tracking and so
that's exactly what you want to do
because when you're looking at your
reports in MailChimp it's going to show
me the top links that were clicked now
if I go into analytics I want to be able
to see how that campaign or how that
link actually performed so let's take a
look at that real quick so if I go to my
Google analytics account and I go to
acquisition campaigns all campaigns what
am I looking for well if I click on
source and medium source and medium are
true the parameters for UTM tracking I'm
going to look for MailChimp so here I
could see my original URL MailChimp and
then the date stamp and then the mediums
email so if I go back here I Can See For
example any one of these meal champ
emails that went out and then I could
see how many people actually came from
the email what the bounce rate was
meaning if they arrived on the side did
they leave after arriving or did they
actually go to another page and then I
could see other engagement data like how
many pages they looked at did they how
much time do they spend more importantly
did they convert so that's the whole
idea behind using UTM tracking because
with UTM tracking you can can bridge the
gap from open rate click-through rate to
behavior on the website all the way
through to the conversion and that's is
what we want to measure we want to
measure did somebody go from the email
open it click on one of the links go to
the website engage on the website and
convert and so that's the whole idea
behind UTM tracking because MailChimp
and any other email marketing platform
is only going to give you at most your
open rates and your click-through rates
okay so here we could see the top links
clicked I see 4 000 recipients clicked
on this email they went to the site and
now I need analytics to kind of tell me
the rest and here I can see what
subscribers have the most opens and if I
integrated social I can see some social
performance and so that goes back to our
original setup so if you integrate your
Twitter account or your Facebook account
you'll be able to integrate that email
in with your Twitter and then from there
I'll be able to see you know tweets or
or how many likes for example and to top
it all off I can see how many people
from around the world clicked on on the
email so that's reporting in a nutshell
on MailChimp reports are fairly easy to
look at you know all sorts of other
information like links specifically
links you can look at Social so if I
click on the social tab here if I
integrated my social I can look at
Social reporting likewise for e-commerce
and notice analytics 360 I can integrate
Google analytics and with MailChimp if I
want to so I have all sorts of options
on my reporting so that's it for
MailChimp I mean it's fairly easy to
navigate you have all the campaigns that
you've set out so if you just click on
campaigns I'll be able to see all the
campaigns I've set up and all the
campaigns that have been sent and
obviously the ones that have been sent I
can start looking at reports I can pick
and choose templates okay I can pick and
choose my audience and manage my
audience okay I can see what the growth
is for my audience again I have
different options to grow my audience
okay I can certainly add 4 form
submissions landing pages sign up forms
I can import more contacts and I can
manage them through different lists
content studio is where all your files
are going to be located from the files
you've uploaded to e-commerce products
to get these to Instagram to my logo and
then you have reports and the reports
are there for you to measure the
performance of your email campaigns once
they've been sent so you can look at
them from reports or just from the main
campaigns view that's pretty much it so
if you're ready to go at it again click
that create button click that template
choose that audience you can go ahead
and send yourself that test email when
you're ready go ahead and send that
email off to your audience it's that
simple in MailChimp we're going to cover
marketing interview questions and
answers so thanks for joining again and
here's how it's going to work so if you
have any questions to these questions or
answers feel free so just comment right
below this video and we'll get back to
as soon as possible we're going to go
through a series of questions and I'm
going to answer those questions for you
so email marketings traditional digital
marketing channels it's been around a
while and you're going to be asked some
questions that aren't going to
accomplish a lot of things related to
the delivery of emails uh we all check
emails on a daily basis we all receive
them sometimes receive emails
unsolicited sometimes we sign up to
receive emails sometimes receive emails
from friends sometimes we receive emails
where we're working or previously have
worked so most people have an
understanding of email however as a
marketer there's a little bit of a
Different Twist to it so we have to
understand the intricacies of how email
marketing works so you're going to be
asked some questions and really the
first question here is what's the
difference between a hard and a soft
bounce email so so if you're a digital
marketer you're in charge of sending out
lots of emails let's just say thousands
or yeah I mean it could be in the
hundreds of thousands of emails you're
going to get some bounces and so you
really want to know the difference
between a hard and a soft bounce so a
soft bounce just means that the email
message reached the recipient's mail
server but bounce back is undelivered so
think of it as delivering actual mail to
a post office so it actually reached the
post office but it bounced back because
maybe the you know person's email box
was full maybe their account was
temporarily disabled or maybe the email
server wasn't necessarily able to handle
that email now hard balance is an email
that that is rejected because it's an
email when it happens when the email has
been permanently rejected so for example
maybe the the the the account is no
longer valid and so let's look at some
reasons again as to why a soft bounce
would happen so for example the inbox is
full or the recipient servers don't so
reach the post office but there was a
problem actually getting it into the
hands of the owner so to speak where the
hard balance a little bit different
let's just say that person is no longer
working their email has been deleted or
you the email has been blacklisted
somehow okay a Spam or something to that
effect so the email server is going to
identify that and it's not even going to
reach the recipient so a lot of
different ways in which an email may not
make its recipient so not the most
important thing to know here I just the
important thing to know is listen when
you send out an email you got to pay
attention to how many get bounced back
and so next question here what would you
do to improve the click-through rate of
your email so click the rate is simply
how many people have seen your email and
how many people actually clicked on a
link in the email so if a hundred people
saw your email but only one person
clicked then it would be a one percent
click-through rate so we want to be able
to make sure we have a high clicked
array so remember emails are going to
people who likely signed up to receive
your email and even if they are
expecting email or they're not expecting
an email you still want to follow some
of these best practices here one is to
create a compelling subject line so you
want to make the subject line something
that people are going to notice take
note of or take an interest in and say
hey what's this all about that's pretty
interesting and open the email so use
preview text effectively obviously you
want to make your email mobile friendly
because most people look at their emails
on their mobile phones you want to
create engaging content okay so the
content that's in the email obviously is
going to have some links so put some
strong call to action in there and
that's one of the bullet points down
below places CTA where it's easily
visible so keep in mind mobile users
most people are going to check that
email on their phone so you want to make
sure you have compelling content with
good ctas in a visible location so
always check mobile as well as desktop
obviously in your emails you want to
make them as visual as possible don't
make them so text Heavy you can always
segment your emails meaning if you're
sending out an email let's just say to
100 people okay maybe you want to divide
it out boys or girls maybe older or
young maybe you know living in one part
of the country versus another part of
the country I mean those are examples of
segments so break up the email don't
send it to one mass email to everyone
that way you can personalize the email
if an email is personalized the chances
of somebody clicking on it are going to
be greater and then a B test your emails
and when we say A B test you know you
could send out the same email twice
except one segment is going to say get
one version of the email the other
segment is going to get another version
in the email and what are the different
versions maybe the subject line so the
subject line is different on version a
versus version b or maybe the call to
action is different so you always want
to send out different versions of the
same email to a different segmented
audience that way you can actually see
which segment or which version got the
most clicks okay so next question here
is how to inform your customers about
company news and establish a
relationship with your target audience
okay so again how do you inform your
customers about what's going on in the
company and how are you going to
establish a relationship with that
audience who's receiving that email well
newsletters are always the best answer
here so somebody signs up for your email
let's just say they actually purchase a
product from you newsletters are great
way to reach out to that audience to get
them to stay up to date with the latest
product or an improved version of the
product they purchased and then that way
they can come back and continue to
purchase the product so newsletters are
a great way to reach out to your
audience and actually talk to your
audience and you're not talking verbally
you're talking to them via email so you
send out that email campaign maybe it's
once a month hey we notice you bought
this product we have similar products
just like the one you bought or hey you
know if it's a software maybe hey we've
we've got upcoming updates to our
software make sure you go to the website
and get the updates or we have a new and
improved version so all these things you
want to communicate to your audience via
email that's going to get them to get to
the website and that's going to get them
to you know purchase more update upgrade
whatever so newsletters the way to go so
again some basic tips here you want to
create your newsletter with 90
educational and 10 promotional so
remember you're sending out a newsletter
to people who likely signed up so you're
educating them about your products
always create interesting subject lines
you want whether they know you are not
you want to create the subject line so
somebody's going to click on it so make
sure you design your emails
appropriately okay so if you know you're
sending let's just say baby products two
mothers or expected mothers in fact this
is a real live example because I used to
work at a gap and Baby Gap was you know
one of the emails groups I was
responsible for so we created an email
template with softer colors your yellows
your your light blue you know it wasn't
black or dark red or anything that's
going to be you know heavy we knew who
our audience was and we designed the
template accordingly and of course using
compelling images so for selling baby
products you put baby product images in
there I mean it's common sense but you'd
be surprised you gotta pick and choose
your images carefully especially if
you're sending to an international
audience because images can be
misconstrued and just like we mentioned
with the click-through rate you always
want to have a clear CTA always make
sure sure you have a CTA in a visible
position because most people are going
to look at that email in a mobile phone
okay and then always make sure you
include your contact information in the
newsletter so somebody knows where to
find you how to contact you where to go
maybe they have a product they want to
return okay so you always want to put
that contact information normally it's
at the bottom of the email but these are
all best practices so here's some
examples okay we've got you know check
out the latest Cosmetics from our new
collections notice the image and notice
the call to action so you can see trendy
collections you know we got some other
products you may want to buy okay five
important skin care products that
everyone should have view more so you
always want to have that call to action
in a very visible place so Define
following metrics open rate
click-through rate and response rate and
forward rate so these are metrics
related to email marketing so you're
going to have to know what these are so
I already mentioned click-through rate
before when we talked about best
practices from improving the
click-through rate so for those of you
that remember what that is go ahead and
put that in the comment section below
just a little pop quiz for you if
anybody remembers click-through rate but
let's take a look at open rate so open
rate is the percentage of the total
number of recipients who actually open
the email so if you send it to x amount
of people how many people opened it that
would be the open rate so how many
people open it but you're gonna take out
the people who balanced it whether it's
a soft bounce a hard bounce okay you're
not going to count those people so if
you have let's just say 20 people open
the email and you send it to a hundred
people then and you had nobody bounce
then it would be a 20 open rate Okay
click the rate again Pop Quiz it's just
how many people actually clicked on any
of the links in your email and that's
just divided by the number of of emails
you've sent out response rate okay so
response rate is the percentage of the
total recipients who clicked on the link
of your email campaign and actually
completed an action so what is that
action well it could be downloading
something watching something purchasing
something so that's the response rate
similar to conversion rate if you're
working in a digital marketing channel
and you're driving traffic inside you
want that traffic to do something well
it's no different in email marketing we
want people to take action we're just
going to divide that by the number of
emails delivered and that gives you your
response rate so let's just say you did
send in 100 emails you did get 20 open
it and of this 20 let's just say one
person went on a purchase well you'd
have a one percent response rate then a
forward rate is simply the forward rate
refers to the rate at which your
subscribers share your email uh with
others friends family Etc and you may
have that as a call to action in your
email in fact that's a best practice so
it's just the number of clicks on a
share divided by the total number of
delivered emails and you're going to
multiple apply that by 100 to get the
percentage and so most email marketing
platforms do measure forward rate okay
let's take a look at how do we capture
inactive customers what you want to do
here is re-engage subscribers with
gamification opt for subject lines like
we have been missing you or did we do
something wrong you want to run a poll
or a competition and re-engage the
subscribers again trying to get people
involved these first three are all about
getting people involved so personalize
your emails talk to that person as if
hey look I haven't heard from you in a
while how about coming back and taking a
look at our new products just as you
would a friend so a design always
matters especially knowing that you're
talking to customers who haven't been
active Okay this is a segmented audience
somebody who's inactive so you want to
have the right design the right message
the right subject line that fits with
that customers inactivity so you want to
try and do everything you can kind of
get that customer back and then you want
to follow a consistent schedule okay so
ideally when you schedule an email you
want to schedule the best time so you
have to know your audience obviously and
then you can always ask for feedback why
are they inactive why haven't they
purchased in a while so the whole idea
here from gamification like trying to
you know make a game out of it so make
it competitive to adding polls to really
personalizing it these are all things
that you can do to get your customers
back so what are the different ways to
segment buy a Persona so again when we
talk about segmentation we're talking
about taking a smaller piece the entire
pie so what's one way to break up that
pie if you will by Geography okay so
with geography you could Target your
audience based on that area and it could
not necessarily have to be by a part of
the country it could be all the way down
to the province the state the actual
City the county okay if you live in a
small village okay all the way up to the
continent okay so think about how you
would break out the segment by geography
now obviously if you break it out let's
just say in the United States to the
southern part well the southern part you
know in the winter in the United States
the southern part is not going to be as
cold as say the northern part so that
should tell you hey if we're going to
send out an email in the winter we're
not going to use snow and and blizzards
as our theme we're going to use probably
a little bit of Sun so breaking it out
by geography helps you understand where
your audience lives you also have
demographic segmentation and this is
simply just age education income gender
you know where people work okay
nationality anything that's going to
identify that user so this is the best
way to segment if you know who your
audience is by income or gender I mean
you're talking to a group of like-minded
people if they're all the same age from
the the same generation and you could
talk to them appropriately okay you're
not going to talk to an older person the
same way you would a younger person so
think about demographic segmentation
because it really helps you hone in on
your messaging and you have behavioral
segmentation so behavioral is based on
your audience's behavior have they
purchased before have they never
purchased were they searching for
something how long do they stay on the
site what products were they looking at
are they a lifetime customer so you can
look at behavior and decide how you want
to break out your emails by behavior and
this is a really good way if you're not
even sure who your audience is or where
they live and how old they are you could
certainly break out your Audience by
Behavior because you know who these
people are based on what they've done
previously because you're going to track
that information with analytics so you
know one way is obviously if somebody's
purchased that's a good way to segment
because you know these people believe in
you believe in your business believe in
your product so the way you can message
to somebody who's purchased before is
going to be different than somebody you
don't even know who they are if they
purchased or not okay so behavioral
segmentation to me is one of the easiest
things the easiest ways to segment your
email list how would you drive repeat
customers through email marketing for
the below scenario okay so this is a pop
quiz if you will again for those of you
that got click-through rate correctly
Kudos let's see if you can go two for
two here okay so if you know the answer
to this go ahead and comment below but
let's just say give a few examples of
subject lines to drive engagement for
audiences based on the following so if I
had an audience between 20 and 30 years
old that were female and the product
were sandals okay what were some of your
subject line speed so I'm going to give
you a minute to think about that and put
it in the comment section below now
remember this is an interview based
question so you're gonna have to think
on the spot I'm gonna give you a minute
but if somebody presented that to you in
an interview you need to be able to you
know react fairly quickly and come up
with some really attractive subject
lines here okay so here you go here's
another one uh so give a few examples of
subject lines to drive engagement for 20
to 30 females for Footwear so you got
Friday sale coming up buy branded
sandals at the lowest price okay so I
like this one because it's got a strong
call to action bye here you go this is
even better because 50 off on branded
sandals and free shipping I mean who
can't beat free anything including
shipping and if it's 50 off I mean these
are key things so you're putting the
promotion and percentage off all in the
subject line so that's really going to
grab somebody's attention weekend sale
for women starts now okay with a little
emoji that never hurts so those are all
good subject lines they all tend to work
because they all have an element of a
best practice in there so here you got
you know the Friday sale coming up is
just giving people notice okay the
stronger call to action on the buy
you're putting the promotion in the
subject line and you know you're using
an emoji to really just drive home the
point so all these subject lines will
work and hey at the end of the day
remember you want to test your subject
lines okay moving on to the next
question speaking of testing what is a b
testing and give some examples of a b
testing okay so we talked a little bit
about a b testing with subject lines so
simply a b testing when it comes to
email marketing it's just a method to
analyze which of the two email campaign
strategies is most effective okay you
know you're going to do it based on open
right you can do it by saying click rate
you can do it based on response rate and
remember you're putting one version of
the email against another version
whether that be the subject line whether
it be the content call to action
whatever so that's ideally what you're
trying to do you're trying to figure out
what works for your audience that's the
end goal for emo for a b testing anymore
marketing what's going to work and I
would highly suggest you should always
do a b testing for subject lines always
so some of the variables that you can
test again subject lines okay you always
want to try if you got a promotion hey
Will the percentage off work likely it
will but let's test it up against
something else like you know a generic
word like discounts you can always test
the design you can always test the
personalization the preview text you
could try out images call to actions
exclusive offers what particular offer
is going to work okay so if you're
testing offers then obviously that's
going to be response rate for testing
ctas and that's going to be
click-through rate if you're testing
subject lines that's going to be open
rate so you want to be able to test
different elements of the email to
figure out what works and what doesn't
work okay so how to prevent email from
getting into spam so if you're an email
marketer this is your worst nightmare
you don't want your emails to get
spammed so oh that doesn't bode well for
you so most email marketing platforms
like MailChimp or Constant Contact
measure spam so some of the important
ways to prevent this is hey improve your
open rate remember going back to the
first question second question you want
to have really good subject lines here
okay and you want to segment your
audience so if you're if you know who
you're talking to and you have a cool
subject line that's going to get
somebody to react and open and that's
going to prevent somebody from spamming
your email okay you can always customize
your from to make it look like it's
coming from in this case Rob Sanders
check if you have included an
unsubscribe link okay so give people the
option to unsubscribe they don't have
the option to unsubscribe they could
just report you as spam make sure your
emails work on different devices okay
you want to optimize your images for
email make sure they're not big and they
don't fit on a mobile device okay prefer
more text and fewer images and then
avoid grammatical issues you want to
come process professional you don't want
somebody looking at your email like who
sent this why are you sending this to me
I don't want to hear from you again I'm
going to spam you you want to prevent
that and that means a professional
looking email professional content with
a really good subject line and some
imagery to go along with that hey you
may just get somebody to open that email
and get them to convert that's the idea
behind it so these are ways to prevent
somebody from actually spamming you and
then what are the best practices for
email subject lines so the subject lines
of most probably the most important
element in email marketing so when we
talked about that little pop quiz with
the sandals targeting 20 to 30 year old
women you know to me I like the subject
line with the 50 off so that was a
number in the subject line so people can
actually see hey wow I get a whole 50
percent that works better than just a
discount okay remember one of those
other subject lines had an emoji so
don't be afraid to include emojis in
there for example when I send out emails
using you know during the Spring you
might want to use flowers perhaps to
signify hey it's spring Winter's over so
personalize the subject lines remember
that goes with segmenting so if you know
who your audience is your subject lines
can be a little bit more personal okay
so opt for title case subject lines okay
so instead of making a grammatical for
example okay you want to keep your
subject lines short and to the point
remember you want to say something
that's going to draw somebody's
attention if you make it long and drawn
out and boring then people aren't going
to open it develop a sense of urgency
like hey we got 50 off through Friday so
that's a little sense of urgency so
people know hey if it's Thursday I
better open this email and check it out
and again grammatical mistakes that goes
without saying you always want to
preview your emails before you send them
out so if you preview your emails before
you send them out have somebody else
obviously receive the preview they can
be another set of eyes for you to
prevent had any mistakes but also give
you feedback on the imagery the design
Etc okay so these are all best practices
for good subject lines okay so subject
line is the most important element for
email marketing so just keep these in
mind subject lines and having good
subject lines is the way to get people
to open it and from there that's half
the battle somebody can open the email
then you've just set yourself up for
better performance
welcome to this content marketing full
course by simply learn we'll begin this
full course by understanding what
content marketing is and some of its
popular strategies then we will see how
content marketing affects SEO and we'll
understand how to rank number one on
Google and YouTube by creating high
quality content
then we will look into the top 10
important content marketing interview
questions and answers
at the end we will look into minor
Concepts like a simple beginner's guide
to content marketing and introduction to
content marketing certification training
by the end of this video I can assure
you that all your content marketing
career related queries would have been
answered for this training with me I
have our experienced content marketing
specialist Rob and Greg jarbo together
they will take you through the various
topics of content marketing so without
any further Ado let's get started before
we begin make sure to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update from Simply learn
greetings everyone and welcome my name
is Rob Sanders from Simply learn and
today we're going to talk about content
marketing strategy so buckle up and
let's get right to it and we're gonna
get right into some of the best
practices some tips some methodologies
some things you should be doing with
content marketing so right out of the
gate let's start talking about knowing
your audience okay so content is all
about writing for a particular audience
so it's just like speaking except when
we're speaking to somebody we're
speaking directly to them content is
very similar and so we have to be able
to know our audience ahead of time so
what you can do is collect demographics
of your target audience based on who's
coming to your website so you can get
that data in Google analytics under
audience email subscribers I mean who is
subscribing to your emails who do you
already have in your email database and
you can look at social media I mean you
look at Facebook you can look at the
people who are already connected to you
okay these are just thumb three three of
many examples you could be doing to
gather data on your audience okay you
have to know who your audience is before
you start writing you know for a
successful content marketing strategy
you really just need to know your
audience and and basically you're going
to segment them based on their interest
so that content is going to be catered
to that audience okay so if it's lines
that likes a specific you know product
uh that you offer or feature that's part
of that product that you offer then
that's the segment you're going to be
writing about so you need to collect
your data on your audience ahead of time
then you're going to segment that
audience okay so you're not gonna write
content for everyone because the shoe
doesn't necessarily fit for everyone
okay the shoe has to fit for specific
foot and in this case we're talking
about an audience we need to be able to
segment our audience out and you could
certainly segment them out by age by
gender by education level by income by
interest I mean these are just some of
the examples again it could be new
returning or new reusers versus
returning users it could be users who
are purchased from you in the past
versus users who have haven't purchased
from you in the past it could certainly
be an age range it could be even going
further on interest level or combination
thereof okay so for example you can get
that demographic information using
Google analytics just got to go in
analytics under audience under
demographics you're going to see age and
age is broken out by age range and then
you see gender so you're gonna see a
breakdown of gender and use that to your
advantage so if you're going to you know
write some content and you know 99 of
your traffic is female the age of 18 to
24 then you know that contents May
catered accordingly so you could
certainly go to Facebook page insights
and get some really good demographic
data there because Facebook is all about
demographics okay so you could see
exactly you know how many fans you have
broken out by man and versus women and
then you can see again same thing as
Google analytics you could see an age
range breakout you could use Twitter
analytics I mean Twitter has share some
really good insights into education
level so you know if you're dealing with
you know highly sophisticated people who
have master's degrees or even higher or
let's just say even on LinkedIn you know
that majority of the people you're
trying to Target are sea level meaning
CEOs or CFOs or CMOS You Know Chief
marketing officers or chief executive
officers then you're going to cater your
message a little bit different than say
mid-range managers or or you know even
high range managers or even VPS so use
your audience information that you
collect on these various platforms to
your advantage okay so let's jump into
number two we want to create high
quality content now I know this sound
sounds like a given but and I say but
heavily yeah there's not a lot of high
quality content out there on the
internet so separate yourself first and
foremost always always always always
create high quality content it's gonna
result in a lot of things are going to
benefit you you know one you're gonna
come across as you know somebody who
knows what they're talking about and
that's going to help increase your brand
awareness okay when you increase your
brand awareness people know about you so
it's likely going to increase traffic to
your website or if you're on social
media you know if you produce good high
quality content people are going to
share that content okay so from an SEO
perspective it can improve website
ranking meaning if you have good quality
content you know and it's really focused
in on a specific topic or a certain set
of core words keywords then you're gonna
rank improves website dwell time meaning
hey you you've got good content people
are going to hang around to see what
else you have to offer okay so it's no
secret that you know good content you
usually leads to you know quality
engagement and then certainly last but
not least you can gain a lot of leads
here meaning hey somebody likes what you
have to say whether it's a video or blog
post or or infographic you know people
are going to become more interested more
engaged spend more time and that's all
going to funnel through to somebody
taking that next step in the funnel and
becoming more interested in your service
or even purchasing one of your products
so creating high quality content
involves brainstorming topics and terms
you know you got to do The Upfront work
due diligence is at work here so
brainstorm some topics use a keyword
research tool to gather results so if
you have a topic you know one of the
benefits of quality content is rankings
go to Google's Keyword Planner
understand and how much quality and and
understand how much competition each
keyword has or understand how much
volume each keyword has that's what's
available in Google's Keyword Planner or
any really any keyword planning tool you
always want to create original content
okay so you don't want to plagiarize or
take somebody else's content and then
you want to support that content with
compelling headlines so if you have a
piece of content you got to get
somebody's attention write a nice
headline that's going to grab their
attention Okay so give valuable content
to your readers and add resources from
well-known sites so if you you do borrow
say a data point from another source
then you know cite that Source you also
want to create engaging and
thought-provoking content get somebody
to think I mean people are going to rage
your content because they not they don't
know the subject matter their interest
in the subject matter and they want to
be able to spend the time taking
something away from that content follow
a logical structure and use relevant
images I can't stress this one enough
you know just throw things on a web page
you know put some structure to it maybe
you have to break it out if you feel
like you have too much content there's
no harm in breaking it into part one
versus part two get people uh tease them
a bit get them to come back and read
part two okay use different content
forms in case somebody's interested
maybe they want to capture some data you
know prefer short paragraphs to make the
content readable remember if you're
talking to c-level folks you know maybe
you don't have to dummy down the content
so to speak but if you're dealing with
you know folks or people that right out
of high school or still in high school
then adjust your content and format and
paragraphs accordingly and then update
the content as well just because you
publish it doesn't mean that it's done I
mean when we're talking about a web page
we're talking about something that is
actively changing or can change the
medium that is dynamic okay so if a data
points change go back in and update that
data point and then let people know
about it because they may want to come
back and and you know check in to see
how much that data points changed so
these are all you know good takeaways
for creating high quality content
there's some other things that you
should be aware of you know grammatical
mistakes you know you need to avoid
those there's no reason for grammatical
mistakes today's technology doesn't
allow for it and Hey listen we all have
friends we have colleagues my desk is
sitting next to a colleague who's more
than happy to read something before it
gets published so take advantage of the
resources you have available no reason
for it because if you have a grammatical
mistake you've just lost a lot of
credibility you know don't be afraid to
add a clear call to action at the end of
your content if somebody's interested in
reading it they're probably going to be
interested in taking the next step
whatever that next step is okay so
created content that fulfills viewers
requirements meaning if somebody's
searching for something and your content
shows up in the search results then
they're actively looking for you what
are you offering them is it fulfilling
their requirements you don't know be
afraid to use examples throughout your
content in fact work in or integrate
some case studies in there show clear
examples to stress your points
and then just don't put words on a web
page you know to break up that content
with an image that's going to be
visually appealing okay and you can add
images from public domain sites meaning
stock imagery if that's what's going to
help create visually appealing content
and then give more information to your
audience and we say prefer to give more
information meaning hey going back to
the content I was saying about breaking
it up organizing it if you have more
information you know don't withhold it
have them come back and read a secondary
blog post or secondary piece that
supports the original now we want to
move from high quality content to
running a B test maybe tests so
important why because with a B split
testing you can increase your conversion
rates okay so four elements to test in
your content marketing strategy so if
you have content say a Blog and you're
testing that blog you test out the
images is test out the forms do you have
a long form or short form you know test
out the content length you can have a
variation that is a lot shorter than the
original does that increase or decrease
bounce rates play around with call to
actions your call to actions do matter
you know do you want to use a softer
call to action a softer tone or do you
want to use something very direct and
strong you know test call to actions to
see what's going to get people to move
closer through the closer to purchasing
and through that funnel so a b testing
to me is something that should be
naturally done with Google optimize it's
free so with images you know you could
test a lot of different variations of
images anything from people to you know
outlandish image rates or just something
very stock and neutral but just make
sure that those images are relevant to
the post you know test the length of
that content you know again if you know
that your average time on page is very
low you know don't write something very
long write something that you think is
going to stick with that time of page
but on your A B test create something
maybe a little longer if it's engaging
enough maybe somebody's gonna stay a
little bit longer on the page so you
know create a variation is going to play
with that length Okay so use analytics
to your advantage to figure out as a
baseline what amount of content is
getting people to stay on the page then
see if you can push the envelope one way
or the other okay improving the page
with sign up forms really what you want
to do is create a user friendly
experience so when you have sign up
forms and don't make them non-intuitive
don't make them difficult you know link
maybe up to Facebook or Google so if
they're creating an account they can
create an account via Google or Facebook
or you know don't put too many forms on
the page and then on those ctas as I
mentioned play around with the tone you
can also play around the color I mean I
test color all the time believe it or
not color does matter don't use red use
green people react to different colors
but again you have cultural variances as
well so you got to take that into
account if you're in the Middle East or
the Far East Asia you know color schemes
and what you say matters and it changes
versus say you know Europe or the West
okay so keep that in mind when you're
making changes on color or tone or
placement and things of that nature so
you want to conduct a competitor
analysis so we're talking about creating
high quality content testing that
content you know brainstorming some
topics you know looking at your audience
you're doing all this work you might as
well take the next step and figure out
what it is your competitors are doing so
you can opt for competitive analysis by
identifying your competitors top
performing content for specific topics
okay and so really what we're trying to
do here is and improve our conversion
rates so what are your competitors doing
what are their baselines we can maybe up
that any I mean that data is also
available in Google analytics so you can
look at benchmarking reports in Google
analytics to get some form or fashion
you can also go to Facebook and look at
your competitors Facebook pages and see
what's performing in terms of Engagement
but what you want to do is find out your
strongest competitors by using search
engines or check which websites are
competing with you and again that could
include Facebook as well or maybe even
LinkedIn so you go with the search
engine route you can always type in that
coveted keyword that you want to be
found for see who's ranking ahead of you
and you can see the metadata meaning the
title tag in The Meta description you
can actually see hey what are these guys
writing that's getting them recognized
in the search engine rankings so you can
certainly if you go to search engine
route you can certainly leverage an SEO
platform form like search sem rush or
Moz or something like that that's going
to allow you to get some good Insight on
competitor information so keep in mind
there are SEO platforms that will give
you information on your competitors and
that's what these SEO platforms are good
for so number five moving on choose a
suitable content format so now we've
done all this homework we know what we
want to say we know who we want to say
it to we're ready to do some testing but
we need to find a format because it's
not always about a web page per se
meaning content on a web page there's
not always about a blog post with
content in that blog post okay we need
to decide the type of content that's
going to fit what we're trying to say so
again you can go the traditional route
with just post in a blog post and
there's nothing wrong with that because
with a blog post you can incorporate
video and imagery you can also go more
more harder route when I say harder more
I say official route with an e-book or
case study something that a user is
going to be able to take away with maybe
download something more official
um something more in-depth something
with a harder stamp on it so that that
shows individuals that you've taken the
time you've done this homework you've
done this research you've done some
really in-depth analysis and now the
proper format for that is not a blog
post it's an e-book now if you're into
talking like I am then you can certainly
do a podcast and podcasts are always
popular depending on the topic so you
got to be aware of the topic now videos
are always always a good option you got
the likes of video and video and YouTube
and some other you know video platforms
out there that allow you the ability to
get found very quickly especially with
the likes of YouTube you know people you
use YouTube before they go on to
purchasing a product so think about that
so if you're trying to get somebody if
you're trying to sway an audience to
move from being a brand awareness and a
loyal you know customer to taking the
next step okay to purchasing more or
purchasing for the first time and so
videos kind of help convey that now if
you're trying to convey a lot of
different points then an infographic
might be your best option instead of
having to write out all those points you
know try using an infographic to convey
those points visually now again with
blog posts it should have valuable
content that can be shared by your
website visitors on social so that's the
key make sure you have those shareable
social icons now with ebooks it should
have longer and in-depth content so and
it shouldn't be published frequently so
maybe if this is something you're doing
annually then ebook could be the format
with a case study what you should have a
customer story that succeeded and and
you solving that customer's problem so
the case study is always there for you
know somebody to get an idea of what
you're all about infographic it's just
visualizing data in a more organized way
in more visual way so somebody
understands what you're trying to convey
now with that podcast again suppose your
audience doesn't have an interest in
Reading again it could be a certain age
certain gender a certain culture hey
everybody absorbs information
differently so think about it ask
yourself is a podcast the best way to
communicate to my target audience and
then videos are highly engaging they're
also shareable on blog posts and pretty
much most if not all social media
platforms so once you've done that once
you choose the proper format you want to
choose a Content management system
that's going to work for you so so you
want to be able to choose something
where you can plan appropriately produce
manage publish and measure results all
in one place there are plenty of content
Management Systems out there that will
help you do all of those things okay so
some examples are WordPress HubSpot
binder I mean we can list hundreds if
you're into blogging you know WordPress
is the way to go if you're into building
on landing pages that you want to you
know share you know hotspot could be the
way to go okay there are lots of
available options out there so moving on
number seven Target your audience using
emails okay so what are we talking about
well we all know what emails are emails
help us to communicate directly with our
target audience and convert them to
leads so email is a good way to follow
up with your audience so if you've done
a podcast follow up with an email you
know maybe get them to to you know fill
out a survey via email based on that
podcast or if you create a podcast about
some data that you talked about in that
podcast follow up that with with them
via email with an infographic perhaps
okay built into the email okay there's
lots of ways that all these formats can
complement themselves via email okay you
could certainly take a blog post and
package it into an email and have a link
pointing back to the blog post maybe as
a teaser or if you're doing a series a
series of blog posts you know you could
tease that in an email so an email is a
good way to you know follow up with your
target audience indirectly or directly
when we say indirectly you know you can
collect emails and send out those emails
with you know certain information or
what you should be doing is targeting
and segmenting your emails just like you
are your content so if you're producing
content for a certain audience then make
sure that particular audience gets that
same email now some of the email content
that you could share with your target
audience or newsletters okay seasonal
emails promotional emails automated
messaging and what we mean by automated
messaging hey if somebody just purchased
from you send them a thank you email
maybe follow up a couple days later with
another email with a survey or what you
could do is if you know who your lawyer
customers are you know Target them with
a promotional email so there's lots of
ways to slice and dice content via email
okay just make sure you know your target
audience is there's lots of things you
can do in email again you can complement
lots of different formats within email
as I mentioned before with a podcast or
a blog post so keep all that in mind
email is a good way to communicate with
your audience okay the last point we
want to make here is use native ads okay
so we talk about Native ads it's one of
the smartest ways to connect your
audience with your brand so for example
this is a native ad on BuzzFeed okay
it's about 15 bands that probably
wouldn't exist without Led Zeppelin okay
so for you folks out there that don't
know who Led Zeppelin is a rock group
from the 70s late 60s 70s okay disbanded
in 80 81 82 early 80s okay but you know
people grew up like myself listening to
Led Zeppelin okay so you could see the
headline here 15 bands that probably
won't exist with the outlet Zeppelin you
know I'm interested in who those bands
might be even if you don't know who Led
Zeppelin is okay you might be
inquisitive to say okay who is this Led
Zeppelin group and what are these 15
bands the key here is not to say the
headline or Led Zeppelin per se but it's
a native ad and it's sitting next to
content talking about music okay so
according to Forbes online audiences are
25 five percent more likely to look at a
native ad than add a banner and so that
native ad in this case we're talking
about music needs to be sitting or
companyed alongside content talking
about in this case music you know would
help if it was rock music just music in
general might get enough to get Peak
people's interest okay so if you're
going to create content you know align
that content with something that's you
know naturally going to fit and that's
why we call them native ads because
they're native to the content that
they're associated with so finally after
all that said and done when all you've
done is create good content follow up
the emails targeting your audience and
associating that content with you know
content natively then you can always
measure your content performance so this
is my favorite part of it all you go in
analytics going to Facebook insights you
know you want to go and check out how
that content is performing and you want
to do that because you want to be able
to see what's performing what's not
performing the key here is associating
the content with kpis that's really the
key so measuring the right metrics can
help you understand whether your content
is engaging or not so again measuring
the right metrics okay so when we're
talking about a video you're not
necessarily going to look at page views
you're going to look at video views so
you know some of these basic metrics of
users and sessions and Pages bounce rate
you know dwell time that's all great but
you just need to make sure that you're
aligning the right metric with the right
asset so for example if you have a case
study and ebook you want to make sure
that you're measuring how many downloads
the ebook or the case study received
again with the video you want to measure
video views now if you're having
cleaning up emails and sending them out
to your target audience you want to make
sure you look at open rates and click
rates okay so a lot of things you can be
looking at so make sure you choose the
right metrics because there's hundreds
and hundreds of metrics to choose from
so just be aware all the different
metrics that are available you know if
you're in it for search okay how much
traffic getting from search where are
you ranking so there are a lot of things
you need to think about so think about
the content that you're producing and
think about how you want to be able to
measure that content so let's go back
over our checklist here so what you
could do is create an editorial calendar
in fact I would highly suggest you
create an editorial calendar in order to
keep track of all the content you've
done over a period of time are you
making your content worth reading that
means are you checking the results of
that content what we just went over
measuring the content is it worth
reading have a column set up in that
editor our calendar you know performing
or not performing if it's not performing
don't do it again okay create your
content okay you always wanna you know
make sure you're reusing or using or
adding to the content that you've
created guest post on influential
blogger websites you want to add
statistics numbers and quotes to your
content make it engaging make it look
like you've done your homework you could
share all your content not just on
social media but you know platforms like
SlideShare now you can share it on all
social media platforms I'd highly
recommend it and again you can even
repurpose it as a blog post so if it's a
podcast then you know you can recite
that podcast in the form of a Blog okay
so get some testimonials that support
some of your content again create a
podcast you can send out an email with a
survey or trying to solicit some
testimonials or if you post something on
Facebook you know leverage the feedback
bag you get from Facebook in the form of
a testimonial okay and then you want to
promote your blog post for maximum
success and a lot of that means SEO so
make sure you do your due diligence and
get the right keywords in that blog post
okay so you can create personas for
different user audiences okay so
remember it's all about tone okay so if
you're going to create a blog post make
sure your tone is aligned with that
Right audience whether that be young
middle aged or older are you choosing
the right type of content okay you'll
know based on the results okay you want
to add H1 and H2 tags on your web pages
why because when we're talking about
content we're talking about organizing
the content and H1 and H2S help you
organize the content appropriately
customize the metadata metadata is title
tag and meta tag descriptions and even
all tags okay all of that is for search
so you want your content to show up in
search whether that's video infographic
or blog post all of it can be shown in
search results so make sure you write a
good title and make sure you write a
good meta description because that's
what people are going to see when they
search okay so you want to create a
detailed summary and title and again
that goes along with the title tag and
meta description and then you want to
make it easy for the audience to ask
questions and comment on your blog so
don't be afraid like I'm gonna do right
now in this video is if I'm missing
anything from this checklist feel free
to comment hey I've written my fair
share content but I could be talking to
an audience that is just as qualified as
I am and they may have some tips so feel
free to comment underneath this video
now don't be afraid to ask just like I
just did people are always willing to
provide constructive feedback so don't
be afraid to ask for it and make it easy
so to me every blog post needs to have
some form of a comment box because blog
posts are out there to solicit
engagement now let's recap everything we
talked about because we certainly
covered a lot and there's a lot to cover
when it comes to content marketing so
one know your audience again you can
lean on Google analytics you know
demographic data whether it be age or
gender you could do the same with
Facebook and Twitter and Linkedin you
know every platform has some data you
could take away create high quality
content when I mean high quality content
brainstorm some topics has it already
been written to death about or is this
unique you know don't write something
your competitors are writing okay don't
copy what your competitors have written
organize your content support it with
good imagery all of these are tips to
creating high quality content okay when
you create that content think about
running some a B test you know run some
variations uh and switch out the image
switch out the call to action see what's
going to get people to react and engage
with the content conduct competitor
analysis so lean on the Facebooks of the
world to see what your competitors are
posting see what's engaging for them
okay you can also lean on these SEO
platforms like sem rush and Moz all you
got to do is plug in a domain and
they're going to give you some
information about where particular
competitor ranks for keyword or how many
backlinks and what websites are linking
to them so all that's available in these
SEO platforms okay so you want to choose
a suitable content format we listed a
few from ebooks to case studies to
podcasts to infographics to blog posts
to videos it's up to you what you think
is best for your audience just keep in
mind you need to be able to measure it
and so that's the important thing if it
doesn't work the first time out then you
might want to consider changing out the
content format choose a Content
management system
um you know plenty out there WordPress
is a good one if you're going to be a
blogger okay blogging allows you to you
know post optimize that blog post you
know you could have the ability to share
that blog post across social platforms
and you can also have that blog post
show up in search engine results so you
can't do any of that without a good
content management system so you want to
Target your audience using emails okay
so email is a good way to again further
communicate with that particular
segmented audience and again you could
use it to send out promotional emails to
Loyal followers or you can use
systematic emails to send an email a
thank you email somebody purchases and
then another follow-up email and again
you can repurpose some of the content
you've done in another format in the
form of an email so you know if you
created a video you know put that video
in the form of an email sent out to your
audience to make sure they're not
missing out on that video you just
created so lots of ways to use email
take advantage of email it's your ally
here okay use native ads okay don't be
afraid to put that content and hear it
with some other content on another
website it's been proven people are
going to engage in an ad that they see
based on the content they're currently
reading because the ad if it's native
it's going to be similar in nature to
the content they're currently engaged in
and then measure your content
performance I can't say this enough make
sure you're leveraging Google analytics
okay with Google analytics or Facebook
insights or Twitter or LinkedIn or any
other platform you're running on they're
gonna have data on what you've posted so
take advantage of it align your kpi so
if it's an ebook or case study don't
measure just traffic measure how many
people actually down downloading them
in most organizations the people who are
doing search engine optimization have
been doing it for a while
and I can tell you because I've been
doing it for a while that in the old
days
it was mostly technical with a little
bit of content sprinkled in so for
arguments like let's say 80 20. 80 of
what an SEO needed to learn how to do
had to deal with you know you know your
meta tags your metadata you know CMS
systems even blah blah blah blah blah
and oh by the way yeah you needed some
content on the page
well here we are a long time past that
and if this you you look through this
slide here for example this is the
latest guidance from Google
on the kind of content they want
and if you look through the list here
most of the items on it aren't technical
and frankly most of it is content and if
you think about it what this means is is
that the job description for SEO has
changed dramatically
particularly beginning with the panda
update but then including the penguin
update and then hummingbird and pardon
me more and more and more seos had
better be interacting with the people
who are creating
quality content engaging content
credible content
um useful content it's not enough just
to put keywords in the right places
anymore on pretty thin content that
won't get you where you want to go
so again
different uh paths maybe the same
direction but the folks in content
marketing and the folks in SEO frankly
need each other and they may or may not
recognize it in your organization but
you know it's a starting point is this a
conversation you you probably need to
have
content marketing is complex
it often overlaps with other elements of
marketing the the most typical overlaps
are with social media marketing and SEO
and they're probably already are
in your organization those kind of
groups
the seos may be on
one floor and uh the social media
marketing people may be in a different
building you know whatever
but the new success formula says we got
to get all those folks to the same table
now we may have to do it virtually we
may have to use you know webinars in
order to hold those kind of meetings who
knows
but the point is is that uh you know the
world is Shifting and organizational
structures need to shift with it
and again you know that's not something
you can change tomorrow
but that is something that will evolve
over time and for what it's worth it
turns out that let's just say uh the
people who are in SEO
they may or may not admit it at first
but they absolutely need to work with
the people in content marketing
why
because basically after Panda and
Penguin the rules shifted
and it's less about your title tag
and it's most mostly focused now on the
quality of your content
and whether that content is link worthy
which means it's really compelling
content it's remarkable content that's
content that's gonna get people to link
to it because wow that's
you know and that's not necessarily part
of the skill set that was required to be
a successful SEO five years ago or ten
years ago
so again you got to get these folks to
the table they've got to work together
you know and um and again that means the
organizational structure probably needs
to shift
and the same is true with the social
media marketing folks
you know they went out and their initial
goals and objectives were you know get
lots of likes you know get lots of fans
get lots of views skip lots of Twitter
followers why because that seemed to be
the metric that the platform gave us
and so we used it to measure success
well it turns out none of those measures
actually measure real success
because they're focused on being
successful on the platform
boy I have lots of fans as opposed to
being successful in business wow that
generated lots of leads and sales
so there is a real real discrepancy
between let's just say the center of
gravity
okay it's not Facebook you're not going
to make a lot of money on Facebook
you know that's just not set up to do
business
you've got to get those folks that
you've engaged in Facebook to your
website where they can buy something
and that's a you know radical shift for
all the folks who are in social media
marketing to say wait wait time out
but that's not what I was told a couple
years ago and the answer is that's
correct what we've learned over time is
that being engaging is useful
if it's harnessed to a benefit and I'll
tell you in most organizations the
social media marketing people are under
a cloud
because they aren't delivering business
benefit
and they too need to learn to work with
the content marketing people
in order to do that and in some cases
they may not be creating the right kind
of content
that actually generates leads and sales
as opposed to
you know is inexpensive to create to get
my next fan or my next Twitter follower
so the key metrics here are no longer
how many likes or comments or shares did
you get that's nice
but
how many sales leads did you generate
what percentage of those converted into
sales
that's a radical change
but again it helps when the social media
marketing people are at the table with
the content marketing people
greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
from Simply learn and today we're going
to talk about how to rank number one on
Google high quality content and talk
about the impact content has on your
ability to get your website ranked
number one on Google so let's just say
you have content on your website and the
content is ranking on you know page four
of Google and it's that blog with ice
cream recipes and if it's just content
for the sake of content is not really
informative then it's not necessarily
going to get good engagement in the eyes
of Google you know they want to rank
content that's very informative it's
very fresh it's exciting to read it's
interesting it's going to have good
engagement so if it's a recipe or an
article about any topic if it's the
content is just non-informative then
you're not going to get good engagement
and when you don't get good engagement
of people don't stay on the site to
engage in the content and they just
leave the website after landing on the
page causing a bounce then the content
is just going to continue to fall down
the rankings and we want to prevent that
we want to move up the rankings we want
to be number one on Google we don't
necessarily want to fall in the rankings
for our content so content is a key
driver in being able to rank number one
on Google so if the content is on page
nine what can we do well we want to be
able to you know take that content and
do something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media and to me
social media is a good platform to share
your content because on social media
platforms like Facebook for example
you're building a community on that
platform that Community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe especially
in the summertime time and you're
engaging with your community on that
platform then the likelihood of that
community on that platform is going to
increase engagement increased engagement
will send social signals to the search
engine that says hey this content is
good quality likewise for any other
platform most social media platforms
have engagement metrics and those
engagement metrics pass signals is it
good is it not good do we like this
content are we giving it a thumbs up are
we going to want to follow it are we
going to want to share it and so if you
share content that you feel is engaging
on social platforms then it's going to
be engaging and it's likely going to
cause an increase in engagement for
example a decrease in balance and once
you share that quality content then the
likelihood of it moving up the rankings
even as far as number one on Google is
going to be greater so you always want
to start out writing good quality
content so let's talk about good quality
content because Google does take content
seriously they do take into account what
other people think of that content so
high quality content is an important
factor so how to create good content
that's always the question so let's talk
about some best practices here remember
in the last segment we talked about
keyword research so we want to perform
good keyword research why because we
want to choose keywords remember we're
choosing multiple keywords per page one
keyword could be related to our brand
one keyword could be related to the
content but another keyword could be
related to a user's intent like recipes
if you recall the example we use with
bread recipes maybe somebody's looking
to type in a keyword that says how do I
make you know a bread or how do I make a
specific type of bread or how do I make
banana bread or what's the best recipe
for banana bread there are question
related and we want to be able to answer
those questions so that's where choosing
those right keywords that's going to
respond to a user's intent so starts
with choosing the right keywords so
remember we talked about a number of
different tools when we talk about
keyword research so there's a research
tool that you can use called phrase.io
and that will help you do quick research
on you know keywords and Trends and
whatnot so if you know about a research
tool that you use for keyword research
then drop us a comment below I'd be
interested in getting your comments
about keyword research and what research
tools are out there so if you know
something better than phrase.io drop a
comment below and we'd be interested in
getting your perspective so keyword
research is key but creating content
that fulfills users requirements so
answering those questions it's a recipe
we want to answer that question if it's
directions we want to answer that
question if they don't know how to do
something we want to answer that
question and that's the whole idea
behind content content is not just to
fill a page it's to really fulfill users
requirements that's when you get good
engagement so if somebody's typing in
something on Google and they're looking
for an answer your content should answer
that question but we also want to make
the content readable so in other words
you know write for your audience don't
impress anybody with very high
vocabulary type words that somebody
doesn't necessarily know the meaning of
don't use jargon don't use a street
language for example use everyday common
language that's just easily digestible
when your audience is reading and then
we want to keep that content organized
and so when we mean organized we want to
use headers and subheaders you know
break your content into paragraphs keep
the flow organized if we can keep the
flow organized then it's going to be
easier for somebody to read and then
it's it's okay to add resources
especially resources from credible sites
so if you can incorporate those
resources in there then it's just going
to add The credibility to your content
let the audience know that hey I've done
my research on this topic and this is
what this person has to say about it
this person who seems to be credible
okay so it only adds value to your
content so these are all tips to
Remember When creating content and then
the one important tip here is we want to
use white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we've chosen keywords that are going
to answer somebody's question we don't
want to stuff those keywords into the
content we want the content to be
naturally written so when we say opt for
white hack techniques that's what we
mean write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include
third-party sources and make sure it
answers a question so there are
different types of content so there's
content where you just right words to
install text-based you could also use an
infographic infographic is simply just a
graphic that visualizes exactly what
you're trying to explain for example if
we want to write an article about how to
write good engaging content we don't
necessarily have to write all that out
as a text we can create an infographic
so for example here's an infographic on
20 effective ways to basically not bore
your readers but write engaging content
so you could see this is an infographic
it's all graphically laid out so
infographics tend to be easier to
understand because they're visual
they're easy for the end user to
comprehend because there's generally no
jargon it's usually images that are
portraying the points of what you're
trying to get across and so it tends to
break it up the monotony of just text
it's more visually appealing and it's
laid out and and organized so you could
see this infographic has 20 different
steps or rules and they lay those out
all here in this infographic and the
great thing I like about infographics is
you could you could share them on social
media you can re-engage them as a post
you can save them from really any social
platform so infographics tend to tell a
better story and versus say just writing
text you can use video and images so you
don't necessarily have to lay it all out
in an infographic you can certainly
insert a video or an image into your
content especially if it's a blog post
if it's a blog post then sometimes video
and images on its own tell the story you
don't necessarily need text to go ahead
and tell your story a video or an image
as they say tells a thousand words and
so images and videos are great to use in
a blog post so so using different forms
of content you know you always want to
review your content when a user dwells
on your web page for a longer time
Google will tend to think okay this
person's engaged so we're going to rank
that favorable so if you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative in
the types of content you use so longer
engaging content tends to bode well with
search engines so this is according to
HubSpot so the more word count you use
the more words you use the chances of
you ranking higher are going to be
better just take into account best
practices you want to maybe break up the
content with an image organize it make
it engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily as words it's the words and
how those words are written how they're
structured the types of keywords you're
using how you're engaging with your
audience there's a lot of factors again
there's best practices we just went over
but the key is you know if you have
longer more engaging content then it's
going to bode better for you on search
engines so a couple of steps to create
high quality content so you want to
begin with a comprehensive introduction
so always introduce your content
remember the content should be relevant
to the keywords so if you're choosing
keywords and your keyword research think
about answering that question if
somebody's typing in bread recipes maybe
they're looking for banana bread recipes
how to make the best banana bread or how
to make banana bread using dried figs we
want to be able to align our content
with that keyword naturally you want to
create a title that's worthy that's
click worthy so remember if you're in
Google search and you're doing search
for something simple like bread recipes
we want to make something that's going
to be you know engaging for somebody to
click on like easy perfect yeast spread
or easy crusty French bread or something
that's going to be engaging you know the
best bread recipes or how to make the
best homemade bread you know something
that's going to draw somebody's
attention to the title of that blog post
so we want to include LSI keywords so
what I mean by LSI keywords in your
content we mean you know long tail
keywords make it natural headings and
subheadings should consist of keywords
and variants so if you're writing
headers and subheaders include the
keyword in there and that way the
content always stays relevant to the
audience okay shorten your sentences and
paragraphs so don't write long
paragraphs remember we want to break
this up we want to make it easy for the
end user to read and we want to always
put internal links on our blog post why
because if we have internal links then
if we have a link from one blog post to
another blog post or say our blog post
to an internal page on our website we
want to make sure that it's relevant
content that way somebody's reading
something and you have an internal link
let's just say from a bread recipes page
to a banana bread recipes page then they
may find it interesting click on that
link and go to the banana bread recipes
page so it's keeping somebody engaged on
your website so putting in internal
linking will help keep the end user
engaged because you're offering up links
that's relevant to the content you
always want to break up that content
with images okay we want to use alt tags
meaning we want to pan the image with
text so that way if the image doesn't
load then at least the alt text will
load so we can incorporate call out
boxes and more importantly we want to
update our content regularly so we
always want to get the best recipe out
there if it's banana bread or different
ways to Crepe banana bread or always
just coming up with ways to update the
content so we want to keep our content
our blog post fresh and then we want to
include a CTA call to action if we
include a call to action then that's
going to keep somebody engaged and have
them act on your content so these are
steps to creating high quality content
and so let's look at an example here and
this is a three-month-old post on
BuzzFeed and it's 21 pictures that
restore your faith in humanity so it has
a lot of likes a lot of tweaks and that
means it's engaged people are engaged
when reading that and so if we go and
look at it as an example we could see it
on a buzzfeed here 21 pictures that will
restore your faith in humanity so this
was written back in 2012. again a lot of
Engagement but if we look at it we can
see immediately that it's taking into
account third-party sources it's got
some content it's got images it's been
broken up by images we could see there's
call to actions on there in the form of
social so people can go ahead and go
ahead and share it if they like it okay
it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because listen you know it's engaging
content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we could see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content so not
just video not just images but text as
well and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
content's updated regularly it's
engaging and it includes sources from
high Authority websites some do's and
don'ts on the content so take into
account the best practices I mentioned
about creating high quality content okay
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know because that
likely is going to be their search and
so you want to be able to respond to the
end user that's part of creating high
quality content different types of
content I.E in the form of infographics
Graphics or videos or text or images you
can add images from public domain sites
you can be relatable and use examples to
clarify points just like the BuzzFeed
article simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language talk to your
audience as if you they were standing
right in front of you and use bullet
points to exemplify your examples your
points so some Do's the don'ts obviously
don't lift content we don't want to lift
content from another website so that's
plagiarism so we want to have our own
unique content we also don't want to
take images from other websites and so
if you do happen to find an image that
works for your post and it's on somebody
else's website ideally that's not a good
situation but if you do happen to do
that then always give credit to the
website okay so if you took it from
xyz.com credit xyz.com for the image and
even put a link back but ideally you
don't want to take images from other
websites just as much as you don't want
to take copy you don't want to take
images use your own imagery and content
but if you don't have imagery then you
can always go to stock photography there
are plenty of websites out there where
you can sign up for a subscription like
Adobe stock images as an example you
could sign up for an account and in some
cases you can sign up for a free account
and use stock imagery okay don't give
less information to your audience give
them to your audience what they deserve
which is the information they're looking
for they're looking for the best banana
bread recipes give them the best banana
bread recipes incorporate your own
images break it up with titles give them
a good quality piece of content that
they're going to be able to engage with
and so if you put long paragraphs in
your content then it's going to be less
engaging so try to avoid those long pair
graphs remember shorten up the
paragraphs keep the language simple add
in images answer those questions use
third-party credible sources but write
it in your own words and you should be
on your way to creating good quality
content creating high quality videos and
some of the best practices around that
so along with everything we mentioned
about choosing the right keywords we
always need to keep in mind that the
videos we create need to be of high
quality so the content itself in
addition to the keywords is a primary
factor in ranking so in order to have
keywords we need to have content and in
order to rank we need to have you know
good content so let's talk a little bit
about creating content and what's
involved with that and what we really
mean by high quality videos so if you
have a video content that is not
informative or irrelevant to the topic
it won't rank so that's just common
sense so you need to create content
that's aligned with the topic obviously
and then that way you have keywords that
are aligned with the content so but if
you have content it really isn't aligned
with the topic then you're not going to
rank no matter how much you've optimized
that video so just keep that in mind so
there's a couple of things we want to
look at here so high quality content is
determined by really two metrics so
we're not sure about how good our
content is and how good of a high
quality video we created we want to look
at audience retention and user
engagement so audience retention when
simply the percentage length of your
video that the audience has watched It's
the percentage your audience has watched
so focusing on audience retention is
important for people who want their
videos to rank high so if you want to
rank you need to optimize for the
keywords but got to keep in mind content
so content is related to audience
retention and user engagement so
audience tension percentage length your
video of your video that the audience
has watched and for example it can be
both absolute in minutes or percentages
so audience retention can be the average
view duration or percentage of the
audience that watched then we have user
engagement so yours engagement of
viewers who are engaged with your
content and so that means they're either
sharing it subscribing commenting or
liking so those are all forms of
Engagement so the percentage of users
who watched or how long they watched
versus engagement or in combination with
engagement are two factors for ranking
so let's talk about some tips for
creating high quality videos so we want
to publish longer videos and so what do
we mean behind longer videos so what's
the reason for longer videos let's just
suppose we have two videos one shorter
in length and one longer in length first
video is 15 minutes long the second
video are seven minutes long so on
average if viewers watch about 40 of
both videos then video x which is 15
minutes long will have more than twice
the watch time of the video that's seven
minutes long so remember duration we
want you know people to watch our videos
longer so if the video is longer in
length if it's 40 then it's gonna have a
longer audience engagement audience
retention so that's one of the reasons
you know from a metric standpoint so
even when viewers watch you know both
videos the time is going to differ so we
want to take into account longer videos
for primarily that reason is because you
know it gives an end user an opportunity
to watch the video longer and then it's
going to help us rank our videos longer
so when we talk about watch time so if
one video has higher watch time than the
other watch time is just the number of
views times the average view duration so
another tip is we want to plan our video
script so we want to keep the content
organized my recognition is you know
create an outline first and once you
create an outline of how the video is
going to flow then start populating with
content and so to me that's how you can
keep the flow organized okay is really
with an outline starting out with an
Omaha there's no videos are no different
than say a presentation if you've done a
PowerPoint presentation you always want
to start out doing an outline then we
want to upload a high resolution videos
high resolution we don't want to create
videos that you know a small resolution
like say you know 400 by 400 resolution
or something you know something really
small we want to create something very
high res so according to back or link
Oaks more than 50 percent of videos on
the first page of YouTube are high
definition so high definition videos of
higher quality are going to be shown on
the first page it more often than not so
high resolution videos organizing the
content publishing longer videos are
examples of creating high quality video
we also want to make sure that content
is relevant to the title so if we're
talking about machine learning Basics
you know obviously the content is going
to be about you know intro to machine
learning or what is machine learning and
then the title should reflect that
content so aligning the title sets the
expectation for the end user so when
they see a title what is machine
learning then when they watch the video
they're expecting to learn about machine
learning and what it is so if it meets
expectations then the chances are that
person who's watching the video is going
to watch it longer and that means it's
going to fulfill the viewers
requirements and when you align
everything accordingly keywords titles
content then at the end of the day the
user is going to watch it and and the
more they watch it the higher the
engagement the higher the engagement the
better chance you have to rank some
other tips that you could use to create
high quality videos so we want to be
able to you know use examples to clarify
our content so you know don't be afraid
to go into another screen like I am if I
want to I'm talking about videos jump
into the machine learning Basics video
which I've done throughout this session
I can simply do that by keeping the user
engaged here this video is about machine
learning Basics well the titles align
with the video we made sure that we have
a nice description about what the video
is about and we're aligning the
expectations so not only that I'm
showing you example within the video
itself so we want to use examples
throughout your video to keep the user
engaged it will also help clarify what
you're trying to express in the video
itself so we want to make it visually
appealing so visually appealing means
imagery or example in the video and then
when we talk about imagery you know you
want to use good images in your video so
I use public domain sites that are
available to you like Shutterstock or
flat icon I mean there are plenty of
those sites out there so feel free to
use any one of those sites to use high
quality images in your video give more
information to your audience okay giving
maximum relevant information can help
gain more views and so when we talk
about more information again it goes
back to you know the examples you use
there's no should be no shortage of
examples here description use all 5 000
characters at your disposal imagery we
want to build up as much information as
you can in the video itself to keep the
end user the viewer engaged we also want
to create original content so always
create original content you could
certainly get ideas from YouTube if you
want to create a video about machine
learning see what else has already been
done do searches on YouTube itself but
you know when you're going to create a
video yeah you can create another video
about what is machine learning but just
make sure it has your own take on it
you're the subject matter expert when
creating the video create it with your
own original content have high audio
quality and video effects so just like
you see here on this video we have
effects in it and the audio is of high
quality meaning no background noise no
Distortion and we want to be able to
speak clearly in the video so you want
to speak clearly loudly concise just as
I'm trying to do now so that you can
understand what I'm trying to say or
what the viewer is trying to to
understand when they're watching the
video so watching and listening are two
of the components and you want to make
sure both of our high quality avoid
distractions we don't want to pause you
don't want to ramble on a particular
Point too long we want to keep users
engaged so you always want to move from
one point to the other intermix it with
examples those are ways to keep keep the
users engaged we want to include
transcripts or subtitles for your video
so transcripts is just more content
that's aligned with the video and the
search engines will be able to pick up
that content and help your video rank so
to me that's a key component to creating
a good video is having the necessary
content go along with the video that
outline I referenced earlier in terms of
organization you always want to have a
Content outline so what topics are you
going to cover in the video that's why
you need the outline to point that out
confirm that before you actually start
creating the video okay focus on the
initial 15 seconds so that's key you
know somebody's going to click the play
button of your video and if you don't
catch them in the first 15 seconds then
they're likely going to pause the video
or just go ahead and close it out
altogether so you want to be able to
capture somebody's attention right off
the bat and even before they click on
that play button you want to make sure
again you're exceeding expectation that
title is aligned with the content so in
your first 15 seconds it basically needs
to be catchy but also setting the
expectation of what the user is
expecting so in this example here we
want to pay close attention to the first
15 seconds that's when viewers are most
likely to drop off so we can look at
audience retention in YouTube so use the
options above the graph to view absolute
audience retention or relative audience
retention so audience retention is
basically how many views a video
received and the percentage of the total
number of video views and that includes
every moment of the video as a
percentage so we'll show you an example
of what that looks like so here we go to
the machine learning Basics video we can
look at the audience retention report
and this is since it's been uploaded the
lifetime audience retention so here we
can see a nice graph the percentage of
people who viewed it and how long they
viewed it so in percentage so here for
example I can say you know 43 44 watch
the video for at least two minutes here
I can see
28.6 percent wash it for six minutes
plus so
dance retention it gives us an idea in
terms of percentage how many people or
percentage of people watch the video at
what length so that's audience retention
so we want to keep that number high at
the very initial stage of the video and
we want to keep it high throughout and
that's why you always want to create
high quality content using those
examples using imagery making it
organized content not pausing you know
going from one point to the other those
are all best practices to keep the
viewer engaged and then we want to add
resources from well-known sites so
throughout this video we've used
backlinko there are other sources we've
used so if you have a source go ahead
and put it in your video to add
credibility and then we want to use
cards to your videos so this cards is
basically a feature that recommends
relevant videos to your audience so in
addition to machine learning Basics
there could be other videos about
machine learning that we can recommend
or YouTube can recommend to the audience
to set up ends screens you want to make
sure that with end screens you can use
relevant videos to your audience towards
the end of your video so you can
recommend relevant videos towards the
end of your video you can also create
playlists so this is a feature that
keeps your audience engaged with
relevant content by Auto playing the
next video so if you enable this feature
it's going to go from one video to
another pattern interrupts keep the
audience engaged so basically it allows
for your audience to stay within one
video without having any interruptions
involved and so going back to the did
you know audience retention report helps
you analyze how well your videos are
engaging to the audience so what do we
mean by that well if I go back again to
my audience retention report how
engaging was it well I could see 42
percent 43 percent watched it on average
of 3 minutes and 21 seconds so to me
that's pretty good of course we always
100 of the video the video is seven
minutes long if almost half of our
audience saw over half of the video then
I would say that's pretty good people
were engaged so audience retention just
is a good report to start looking at to
help you understand how engaging is my
video and if your video is not engaging
you know you can always go back and edit
it or fix it or tweak it so remember the
average view duration for all videos and
top performing videos listed by all time
we can look at that information as well
in addition we can look at demographics
so we can get an overview of the age
gender and location and we can look at
playback locations report and what the
playback locations report does is it
helps us determine the platforms where
our videos are being streamed from
within YouTube think of the traffic
sources where did the viewers come from
devices did they look on mobile or
tablet and so if there's any doubts you
know if you have any questions please
drop a comment below but especially if
you have any doubts on the metrics so if
we go back into YouTube we can look at
analytics and if we're looking at
analytics we can see more and then this
is going to show us everything we need
to see from device type so if I click on
more I can see my playback location so
this will show me where the video is
watched it was on a watch page or a
channel page I could see the traffic
sources I could see the gender and age
so if I click on the viewer age report I
can see the percentage of views by age
so I can get a lot of information
about my video and how it's performed
who's watched it what they've done with
it where they come from all the
information they need to know okay so
it's all within YouTube analytics so
again if you have any questions about
that you know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to YouTube you
may have some questions but just know
that every video you publish to YouTube
high quality align with your keywords
you're going to be able to view the
metrics by looking at YouTube analytics
now before we get into the
t-shirt on what
on what content marketing is a form of
marketing that involves the creation and
sharing of online content to help
generate audience interest in a Brand's
product or services this means providing
information that the audience considers
valuable and relevant in a consistent
manner so that it drives some sort of
profitable customer action
so let's talk about the content that
falls under content marketing there's
options like blogs videos
infographics case studies white papers
and ebooks
so why is content marketing so important
firstly it helps build awareness trust
and loyalty in your brand
the more your brand provides accurate
and well-researched content the more
people learn about and trust your brand
the more the audience trusts the new the
more they're likely to buy from you
creating the content is relatively
inexpensive and can be done in-house
content marketing will also enable your
brand to increase traffic to your site
and get more conversions
it also helps improve other marketing
tactics like search engine optimization
social media and public relations
now let's have a look at the content
marketing process
the first step is to determine what
goals you want to achieve with your
marketing campaign it could be increased
conversions website signups and so on
then you set up buyer personas from
among your audience that can buy your
content
but what exactly are buyer personas now
these are research-based profiles that
represent your Target customer buyer
personas help you describe your Brand's
ideal audience the decisions they make
the challenges they face their interests
and so on
next you'll have to set up content
audits to determine the best type of
content that works for you
you also need to set up a Content
management system like HubSpot
Squarespace Wix and WordPress they'll
help you with increased collaboration
greater support run a B test and much
more
you need to brainstorm for new forms of
content that your audience can enjoy
after that you can zero in on a
particular form of content that would
work the best for you
and finally you can publish and manage
your content now let's talk about
content marketing tips
number one remarket your content content
marketing is one of the many ways you
can spread your content to a brighter
audience you can Define the audience you
want to Market to and then tag visitors
who come to your site and using Google's
Display Network you can strategically
position your ads in front of people on
Google or its partner websites who
previously interacted with your website
and advertise to them
through this you can build awareness and
engagement with your audience
here's an example of a banner
advertisement I would be shown if I was
shopping for a MacBook Pro on Amazon and
changed my mind at the last moment
this ad would maybe stay at the back of
my head until eventually I go and finish
that purchase
now let's go to number two answering
complex questions with your content
targeting specific keywords is extremely
helpful with your content this is why
you need to focus on Google's featured
snippet disposition also known as
position 0 enhances and draws user
attention on the search engine's result
page
through the featured snippet you can
drive a large amount of traffic to your
website while cementing your position as
an expert in your industry you can have
different forms of Snippets like
definition boxes where a snippet of text
gives researchers direct and concise
definitions and descriptions you could
have tables where data is taken from the
page and displayed in a table you could
have ordered lists where items are
presented in specific order and you can
also have unordered lists
next up number three we have create a
personality for your brand if you're
looking to grow a following for your
content try not to copy how already
established and successful corporate
blogs do things nowadays audiences tend
to prefer content that has a certain
humanness about it
tend to follow solo influencers they
advertise their brand by being
themselves
in a way they're selling themselves by
being themselves
you need to analyze what is popular and
influential blogs are doing and
incorporate into your Brand's website
thanks to this your audience will
connect with you and come back for more
now here's an example of one of the
largest players in digital marketing
Neil Patel see how he himself is the
brand and if you've gone through his
content you know it's pretty great as
well
that's what you should be striving for
moving on to tip number four ensure that
your content matches your Brand's voice
to make sure of this you need to
constantly review your editorial
standards and make sure your tone and
quality remain consistent you need to
ask your audience questions about how
you can develop and refine your Brand's
Voice by answering these questions you
can provide your audience with a more
cohesive and helpful experience your
tone of your brand can vary on the basis
of what type of content you are planning
to post and what the goal you want to
achieve from the campaign next up we
have number five back up your Arguments
for data
using statistics and facts to make a
point by including a link to the
original Source makes it extremely
credible this data can help the audience
grow trust in your brand to persuade
them that your content is valid and
valuable this will also help your brand
grow as an industry expert
at number six we have use specific
keywords
now make sure you use specific keywords
in your content this takes care of the
SEO aspect behind your content this will
also help your content have a greater
chance of being found indexed and ranked
it could also help your content rank for
Niche topics within your industry moving
on to tip number seven evaluate the
success of your content with data
earlier we talked about why it's so
important that you backup your content
with data now let's talk about how data
can help you improve
analytics tools will help you learn more
about how well your content is doing the
age demographics of the people enjoying
it who doesn't their locations the best
time to post and much more with this
data you can make sure that your time
and money are being used in the best
possible way some of the most popular
tools in the market are bussumo Evernote
HubSpot Trello and WordPress
these will help you find topics and
influencers within your industry you can
capture organize and share notes
collaborate with team members create
sales funnels and much more
now we've reached Midway right now so
I've got a question for you
do you guys have any tips for Content
marketing that we haven't covered yet
let me know in the live chat
alright so let's get back to our list
tip number eight is to be consistent
with your content
post your best performing content and
make sure they follow a consistent
schedule
finding a balance of the different types
of content to be posted with the help of
a Content calendar will show your
audience that you're committed to
providing them helpful and informative
content
this will also establish your brand as
an authority and thought leader within
your Niche it will help your audience
depend on you for quality content and
give them a reason to return tip number
nine is to make your content actionable
providing actionable steps or
information in your content will coerce
your audience to take a particular
action quickly it can help you create
valuable content and fix pain points
faced by your audience build a strong
relationship with them and earn their
trust it also leads to increased
engagement and a positive brand
experience it provides users with real
value and solutions leading them to take
action here we have an example from
Trello where we see a pop-up with a call
to action asking interested users to
input their email IDs to sign media
today involving more than 200 marketers
more than 49 percent of them felt
content marketing was really important
to their digital marketing campaigns and
more than 25 percent of their budgets
are used for visual advertising content
like images infographics videos and
other forms of rich media will help you
enhance the message of your brand and
reach a wider audience here's an example
of advertising by Coca-Cola
although there's not a lot of text in
the ads you can immediately recognize
the unmistakable branding and the
message they're trying to send moving on
to tip number 11
create trending and Evergreen content
creating content that's Evergreen and
trending with your own unique angle
statistics and research will be a huge
advantage since you'll have to update it
every now and then you'll get a great
deal out of the work without having to
do a lot of work
here's an example of one such Evergreen
article people are never going to stop
wanting to learn how to do SEO so with a
little tweaking every few months to
reflect new changes that Google may have
done you'll have an article that you can
get considerable mileage out of next up
tip number 12 is to understand content
that works for you
you need to analyze what content works
on different social media platforms for
example you all know YouTube is the best
place for video content Instagram and
Pinterest for visual content Twitter for
smaller Snappy content and so on
understanding what works and what
doesn't will help you better spread your
content across the internet
tip number 13 is to understand your
target audience
now like I mentioned earlier your
marketing campaign isn't going to bear
fruit without targeting a specific
audience
understanding who your audience is is
one of the most important steps for this
you can find this out by asking
questions like who you're engaging with
online their age location language Etc
by using social listening to find out
what audiences are talking about your
brand using tools to research what
social channels your audience is using
and so on
after understanding them you can set up
buyer personas for your audience
tip number 14 is to perform a b testing
now ABS testing will help you understand
what your audience likes or doesn't what
content works for you and much more you
can do a b testing on headlines and
title tags call to actions content
formats image types content length and
much more it can also help you make
better decisions in the future
and finally our tip number 15 is to
reach out to people sharing similar
content
one of the best ways to build your
audience is to get people or influencers
who already shared content within your
Niche to share your content
now since these people already have a
trusting audience they would be a lot
more likely to enjoy your content
content marketing interview questions
and answers so thanks for joining again
and here's how it's gonna work so if you
have any questions to these questions or
answers feel free to just comment right
below this video and we'll get back to
you as soon as possible we're going to
go through a series of questions and I'm
going to answer those questions for you
starting out what are the essential
components of a good web content okay so
essential components okay so what do we
want our content to do well we want it
to be useful so web content should be
written in a way which caters to what
the reader wants okay so somebody's not
going to read your content if it's not
useful for them okay this because it
affects reader engagement okay so if
it's not interesting it's not useful
somebody's just not going to read it
plain and simple it also has to be
engaging so listen even if it is
relevant to a user you still have to
write the content so it's engaging so
you want to add elements it's like
imagery videos hey you can even turn
your content into an infographic okay
you want to do something that's going to
be engaging for the user if it's
engaging they're going to read it and
engage with the content okay and then
good content should have some call to
action so content must be written in a
way that can drive call to action okay
so if you're writing a blog post you
know I've seen a lot of blog posts just
simply start and with good content but
it doesn't leave the user with anywhere
to go so have that call to action put
some internal links in that content give
somebody a place to go after they're
done engaging with the good content you
write okay so some other things to think
about some other components for good
content well credibility so you know
anybody can write but are you writing
about something you know what you're
writing about are you a good talking
point a good expert or have experience
about this content so you also want to
use you know info information from a
legitimate Source okay so you don't want
to grab something in your and use it in
your content that's just not legitimate
because it does hurt your credibility
and the organization's credibility and
then also originality I mean write
something that nobody else has written
so obviously you don't want to
plagiarize because if you plagiarize and
there are tools out there where people
can easily just put their content in
there to see what else is out there see
if somebody else has plagiarized it so
it's very easy to find people who
plagiarize so don't be that person what
I would recommend create a good content
calendar and come up with some ideas
before you write them next question
related to content marketing so what are
the types of content you can create well
there are a lot of things you can create
start with the blog blog to me is always
a great place to start it's a blank
canvas for your ideas your thoughts your
opinions okay that's a great thing about
a Blog it it accentuates personality you
can create a video videos are always
engaging you can create an infographic
infographics to me or you know Hidden
Gem instead of somebody reading the same
old same old you're laying this out in a
very visual way that's easy to
understand create a case study okay so
if you're you know digital marketing
expert you've done social media for
another client you know write about it
you know show the successes show that
you are an expert show that you've
created successful campaigns and social
and in the form of case study you can
create a white paper white papers are a
good educational pieces you can also
create an ebook Okay ebook hey if you
have a lot of content you want to lay it
out and ebook's a good way to go and you
have a lot of choices here when it comes
to content a lot of choices okay so what
are the advantages of having a Content
counter so I alluded to that just a
couple of seconds ago so let's really
break this down here because content
counters to me are so important well
first of all counterpart of content
count owner allows you to think about
dates so if you're planning something
you're going to have important dates in
mind okay so content calendar and almost
ensures you don't miss anything you know
that's a good opportunity for you to
leverage like you know Black Friday
Cyber Monday you know it's probably
important you know when those days are
if you're in e-commerce so that's why
having a Content calendar helps it helps
you plan out your content based on
important dates or based on dates that
work for what you're trying to do they
also help because you could stick to a
consistent schedule okay so if you don't
have a Content calendar you're probably
just arbitrarily writing content here
and there well what if your users crave
and really engage with the content
they're going to want more sticking to
something consistent is going to really
get people to come back for more they
know when you're going to post they're
going to be waiting for it and if it's
every Tuesday Morning eight o'clock hey
post it Tuesday morning 8 o'clock your
users will get used to that schedule and
and it does help build up your following
it does help to help build up your
community and in the end cultivates a
long lasting relationship and having a
allows you to mix up your content okay
so you can see and plan ahead different
types of content in different formats
that way it allows you to mix it up okay
whether it be a blog post uh an
infographic a video about different
topics okay some other advantages here
saving time it just allows you to
prepare for the future when you can
prepare you're efficient and when you're
efficient you're not wasting time and so
to me having a Content calendar is a
must because a lot of us are busy who
has time and especially if you're going
to work in a new company let's say
writing content you definitely want to
have a Content counter because you're
going to want to use that time to
efficiently plan this is a new company
you're going to start working at you
want to understand who this company is
what they've done in the past what you
haven't done and what you want to do
okay so all of that helps you plan and
prepare and it saves you the time and
effort and hassle down the road and then
then at the end of the day you want to
be able to figure out what works so
planning your pose puts less strain on
you and your team members as well as
company resources because when you plan
and you post you're going to get data
and then when you get data it's either
going to work or not work and if it
doesn't work then you know in the future
you're not going to put that piece of
content or that topic in the content
calendar again it's that simple okay
some other advantages fresh content okay
so having a con content calendar allows
you to always keep content fresh again
you're going to be on a consistent
schedule and you're not going to be
writing about the same things over and
over again so it could be just simply
Twitter if you're putting a Content
calendar and together for Twitter well
you don't want to have the same tweets
every other day so it does ensure that
you're getting tweets out there that are
fresh that are new that are different
and again figure out what works a
Content counter makes it easier to
measure results and optimize performance
so you always want to you know maybe put
some metrics in with your content
calendar so you can see side by side
content historically that is performed
content that is not performed okay so
next question you may get what type of
content Works in each stage of the
customer life cycle so you have
awareness engagement purchase post
purchase advocacy okay so let's break
these down here so awareness okay so you
want people to understand who you are
okay that could be a guest blog an
influencer helping you out it could be a
cold email a video that can potentially
go viral a social media post introducing
a product you have engagement so you
want people to engage with your content
what are you going to do to get people
to engage well you could certainly write
an email and have people open that email
and go to your website you can have an
ebook where people can actually download
and read it or you can have a Blog where
people can comment or landing page where
they can fill out a form submission you
have a valuation so with social media we
know there's a lot of Engagement going
on but when you're putting content out
there you can certainly open it up to
testimonials okay you can generate white
papers okay or you can generate case
studies case study is a good way for
companies to evaluate what you've done
in the past if you've worked in it for a
specific product in the past and its
works you certainly want to put that out
there for potential clients in that same
industry purchase trying to get people
to purchase what are you going to do
well you can certainly have landing
pages a nice you know website a nice
shopping cart with some nice content
okay onboarding emails get those emails
out there and get people to go back to
the website and purchase of course you
can have product and service details as
well meaning you know one one page
downloadable PDFs that describe the
product okay yeah post purchase okay so
people who've already purchased you
could certainly send out follow-up
emails and you can do blog roundups you
know give people an opportunity to see
what features or updates are happening
to the product of course case studies of
repeat customers or content types that
detail a new feature or service okay so
if somebody's already purchased and you
may want to send them some content of
another product that complements the
product they bought so a lot of things
you can do to engage with your user
who's already purchased and then
advocacy you want people to help you out
here so have the user generate the
content you can have exclusive discounts
for your community they're going to be
your Advocates so give them exclusive
discounts and then pictures of customers
engaging with your products okay who's
not going to share that so you're going
to have people share that information in
other words you can generate content
where hey people can help you out here
and be your Advocate okay so how do you
decide what topic and subject to write
on okay well going back to the content
counter that always helps you can see
what you've put in that content calendar
but there are some other method you you
can use and you could certainly identify
your target audience and not only
identify your target audience but what
their needs are okay so you can write
content based on audience you could
certainly do some research with keywords
okay what's trending what keywords are
not trending okay and right around
what's trending for example okay you
could certainly take a look at social
media for example quora I always look at
quora core is interesting entertaining
informational hey people are certainly
having conversations on Quorum and you
can certainly analyze those
conversations because they certainly get
in depth and you can decide hey do I
want to write a topic around something
that really just won't go away in terms
of conversing core is a good example of
analyzing conversations they tend to be
a little bit more in depth so some other
things you could do you can look at your
competitors and what kind of
conversations are happening on your
competitors blogs or your competitors
social media platforms and Pages you can
keep track of blogs and articles from
subject matter experts commentators
critics and so on okay so you can get
ideas from them another question you may
get which is very important if you're
going to start working for a company you
need to understand the tone the tone of
your content because that is going to
fit and be in line with the company
you're working for okay so you're always
going to have a brand personality so the
characteristics of a brand or the
guidelines based on which the content
strategy is developed the tone of the
content must align itself to the content
strategy your audience profile so you
got you need to determine who your
audience is okay and how the brand wants
to be seen by that audience so you know
if you have an older audience you're not
going to use younger audience I.E street
lingo or today's lingo and and the
younger generation you're going to use
you know language that's going to fit
the audience you're talking to and then
of course the channel itself so the
content you create must be irrespective
of the channel consistent with brand
attributes okay so you gotta pick and
choose the channel if it's LinkedIn for
example hey you know linkedin's more
business oriented okay so you're not
going to be you know as humorous as you
would be say on Instagram or Facebook
all of these have one thing in common
again that's brand guidelines you have
to stay within the brand what is the
Brand's personality how do we want to
talk to our audience and what platform
are we using to talk to our audience how
do you promote your content once it's
live well that's always a good question
hey you doing the the work the putting
in the hard work to create this you know
it could be a video and videos take a
long time it could be an infographic an
e-book okay so send it out via email
okay if you haven't an email list send
it out and let people know this
content's there put a link in the email
or or even a piece or snippet or preview
of the content in the email so you're
using the email to broadcast and
encourage people to you know if it's any
any book get the rest of the ebook Okay
you can certainly leverage social media
to engage with your community that's the
best you know just as good as email get
out there and let people know hey I got
I got my book published come and
download it you know you can give a
discount to the first 100 people that
download it okay you can always promote
your content via ads so whether that be
Google or Facebook you always have an
opportunity to meet more prominent by
advertising the content that you have to
offer so you can always reach out on
social media again targeting interesting
people directly so you can always
interact with people on social or you
can write for others attract people from
the web to important pages of your
website by guest posting so you can
always go on to a popular blog post and
write something and you know link it up
or or have it be relevant to the content
you've written so next question how can
you determine how well your content is
doing okay very important again and
you've done all the work you put the
content calendar together you got the
content ready to go it's published
you're promoting it social email guest
blogging but you want to determine how
it's doing well depends on the channel
really is what it comes down to so if
it's organic search you want to be able
to see if it's ranking for the keywords
you optimize that content for if it's
social you want to be able to see if you
have engagement shares comments Etc of
course you can always look at analytics
and see how much traffic that blog post
is getting or that page with the white
paper is getting okay so you can always
look at your analytics and look at the
traffic okay and again you can always
look to see if there are conversions in
the form of an inquiry or lead or sale
so at the end of the day you want to
align the content with the channel and
you want to line the kpi with the
content and channel okay so if it's
social you're not likely going to get
conversions unless you're doing paid ads
if you're posting organically on social
then you're probably going to get some
engagement so you have to align the
right metric with the right channel what
are the steps involved in the content
marketing process okay so you really
need to decide what goal you want to
achieve with the content marketing
campaign so that goes back to what I was
just saying a minute ago if you have
content you post it on social then
what's the goal what are you trying to
achieve well you're probably going to
get engagement and likes you need to
Define buyer personas to determine the
audience best suited for your content
okay so you're always writing for an
audience and you're going to Market that
content for that audience so you always
got to keep that in mind okay run
content audience to the audits to
determine the best type of content that
can be used in other words how did it
perform what kind of Engagement did you
get with the infographic or did that
video really really perform well or do
we want to use you know a blog post next
time around or an image next time around
so continuing on here you want to choose
an appropriate content management system
okay so how are we managing all this
content okay is it WordPress or is it
another platform okay you could start
brainstorming for ideas for new content
so again that goes back to the content
calendar you leverage your content
counter to always create ideas for new
content okay then you want to settle on
a particular type of content that you
want to create okay so once you come up
and you're managing your content you
know you've come up with some ideas then
you obviously want to choose the format
and then of course you want to publish
and manage your content after it's all
said and done so these are the steps
involved again just quickly decide on
the goal the kpi decide on your audience
look at what's worked and not worked in
the past get your content set up in the
platform okay we'll get the platform
ready to go I I should say Okay generate
ideas with that content count or I
ideally go to the content calendar for
the ideas choose that type and then
publish and manage and when I say manage
I mean again going back to analytics or
going back to the kpi that you align
with that content to see if it's
performing or not okay so next question
here how do you target the Right
audience for your content it's a very
good question you're not writing content
for everyone let's be honest here so you
have to collect demographics of your
target audience based on who's coming to
your website based on who subscribed to
your emails based on who's following you
on social media so in other words you
have people interacting with you okay in
different channels and you need to
understand who these people are so or
they fit a certain age range or
generation are they skewed more female
to male education level what's their
Affinity or interest okay do they have a
certain income so you need to really
break down down your audience here and
you could do that in analytics you could
do that on social you can do that just
by looking at your email list okay the
all those will paint a picture as to who
your audience is I'm Greg gerbo I'm a
member of the market mode of faculty in
this first section we're going to talk
about what content marketing is how it
works and also explore why it works
this seems like a new buzzword to you
it's actually a term that's been around
for quite some time
it's just web search interest in content
marketing has tripled since 2010
according to Google Trends and that's
why a lot of people are now just
starting to get their arms around it
so what is content marketing well
according to Rebecca Lee a friend of
mine who wrote an article in advertising
age content marketing is not just a
glorified way to say social media
marketing it's actually a little broader
concept so content marketing does
include social media and you can use
blogs Facebook Twitter Youtube Vimeo
LinkedIn Google Plus Pinterest
Foursquare Instagram Flickr StumbleUpon
Tumblr SlideShare and quora and you can
put all of those together in a Content
marketing program
and all of this content
can be optimized so it can be found in
search engines as well as in social
media or in the usual places like your
website
one of the ways to sort of conceptualize
this is the classic Venn diagram
Brian Clark of copy blogger has put
together a really interesting white
paper called the business case for agile
content Marketing in which she's created
this particular diagram that shows
search social and content and the
overlap of the three is where he
positions content marketing and that may
help you understand where it fits it's
sort of a little bit of this a little
bit of that but it also shows you both
the potential leverage that you can get
when you begin combining these elements
but also the potential conflicts you may
encounter inside an organization who
says hey wait a second that's my job and
the real challenge to content marketing
is getting people who have been doing
their job independently headed off in
their own unique direction to actually
collaborate and coordinate what they're
doing and leveraging each other's
capabilities to create something that's
a little more powerful
in the world of digital marketing you
must have heard the term copywriting
but very few people talk about
copywriting it's one of the essential
skills for any digital marketer it has
been estimated that there are 1 lakh 31
200 copyrighters in the United States
today it is projected that the
copywriting job market will grow by 7.6
percent from 2016 to 2026.
freelance market for copywriting is on a
roll companies like upwork and Fiverr
are filled with copywriters there are
many advantages of freelance copywriting
jobs like being Your Own Boss a flexible
schedule and doing what you love what is
copywriting in simple words copywriting
is a type of writing or a set of words
that will convince the reader to take
some kind of action and that action can
be anything like registering for an
event signing up for something or buying
a product businesses usually hire
copywriters to write landing pages
Facebook and Google ads copy social
media post Etc in order to convince the
readers to take some action copywriting
should be part of any marketing plan and
is one of the most powerful ways to
capture the attention of your target
audience and motivate them to convert or
purchase copywriting is everywhere when
you go online or even offline remember
the Google ad that you see when you
search for something in Google that is a
copy or if you check your email box you
will find different promotional mails by
different companies that are a copy
basically those companies are trying to
convince you to take some action it can
be anything for example an e-commerce
company will convince you to purchase
some of their store products
now let's talk about the copywriting
formula a good copy usually follows Aida
formula a stands for attention I for
interest D for desire and a for Action
almost every good copywriter uses this
formula to write better copies and it's
important for you in case you decided to
become a copywriter or want to use
copywriting in some of your work so I
hope now we understand what actually
copywriting is now let's try to
understand what does a copywriter
actually do
the copywriter's job is to write words
that convince an audience to take some
action for the benefit of the company in
which the writer Works let's have a look
at sample copywriter job description
that will help you understand the role
and responsibilities and the skills
needed for this role
so firstly let's have a look at
responsibilities writing editing and
Publishing engaging content for various
social media Network including Facebook
Twitter Instagram LinkedIn and Google my
business optimizing social media post
language tone message based on your
target audience Behavior selecting
appealing images and videos to
complement text for designers to design
the post
let's have a look at some more
responsibilities coordinate with
internal teams to create advertising
posts for client respond to questions
and comments on social media Pages
promptly and accurately there can be
more responsibilities to a copywriter
depending on what the company needs so
it varies from company to company now
let's see what skills a company looks
for in a copywriter
hands-on experience using various social
media platform to advertise solid
knowledge of SEO keyword research and
analytics tools example Google Analytics
familiarity with online paid advertising
let's have a look of some others
requirement and skills
ability to deliver creative web content
text image and video excellent
communication skills
so now we know what copywriter does
let's explore its various types
SEO copywriting it means optimizing the
copy using keywords to make it rank at
the top of the search results for
example if you optimize a company's
product page correctly through SEO
copywriting then there is a high chances
that your sales page would rank at the
top of the search result which would
result in more sales next we have social
media copywriting this type of
copywriting is used on social media
platform for example a catchy title is
used to grab the attention of the user
and Emoji is used to make the copy
interesting or frame the right message
in order to convince the audience to
take some kind of action next we have
technical copywriting the motive for
writing technical copy is to explain the
latest Technologies or the technical
product that a company wants to sell for
example if you have a tech product you
need a copywriter who can explain the
technical aspect use case of the product
and how that product help the customer
direct response copywriting it is a type
of communication that is compelling
enough to be able to influence the
customers to act in other words what any
copy that encourages the recipient to
act immediately and the response from
the reader are miserable another type of
copywriting is Public Relation
copywriting in Public Relation
copywriting you write newsworthy things
to catch your audience attention and
gain their trust it helps you quickly
earn an audience with credible sources
and as a result your business can
promote its product and services more
effectively whenever you search on
Google you see some ads at the top of
the search results that are also made up
using copywriting following that next we
have ad copywriting this type of
copywriting is used to create effective
ads generally it's used in Facebook and
Google ads now we reached the second
last type of operating in the list which
is email copywriting as you understood
by the name all the copy that we use in
emails are email copywriting it includes
a good subject line nice preview text
and intro sentence for the body of your
email and a strong call to action now
let's discuss our last type which is
brand copywriting brand recognition and
connecting with customer begin with
communicating what your brand represents
your brand image can be conveyed through
writing it can be in the form of logo a
song or a phrase to create brand copy
you have to think about your customers
first with this we have come to the end
of this copywriting types list before
jumping into the next topic I have a
task for you just pause this video and
in the comment box type your favorite
type of copywriting I hope you are done
with the comment let's move forward to
our next topic which is difference
between copywriting and content writing
firstly let's discuss the difference
based on the overall goal copywriting is
a type of writing aimed at selling a
brand on the other hand content writing
is all about building a perception in
consumer's mind the next difference is
based on the length of the content a
copywriter typically writes short form
of copy and a Content writer writes long
form of Copy Text written by copywriter
is brief and engaging content writer
often have to write more in-depth
content explaining a process or topic
now what's the difference when it comes
to a role in a company a copywriter is
someone whose primary role is to create
copy and a Content writer often does
more than just right it may be a writer
blogger executive or anyone else
lastly let's discuss the difference
based on SEO a good copywriter
understand SEO but when it comes to a
good content writer they should know
about the advanced SEO now let's explore
some of the helpful tools for a
copywriter copy AI it's an AI tool and
the greatest thing about this tool is
it's very simple to use you can generate
Instagram caption product description
and even product value proposition by
just providing a few words it's a paid
tool but it has a 7 days free trial the
next tool that we have is grammarly
grammarly is a free online tool that
finds mistakes in your writing and
suggest improvements as you write
grammarly will underline any mistake you
have made and offer suggestions on how
to fix them additionally it has a
plagiarism Checker and a punctuation
checker however for additional features
you need to go with grammarly premium
what tune with the help of grammarly you
can fix your writing mistakes but when
it comes to rephrase and rewording your
content without sacrificing flow tone or
meaning word tune came into the picture
hence the combination of grammarly and
word tune is the best for the copywriter
and it's a paid tool but have a free
plan for beginners
the last tool in our bucket is Wordsmith
if you rely on data in your day-to-day
decisions Wordsmith is a perfect for you
it can be used for everything from
journalism to financial reporting
because it produces natural sounding
content simply create one template and
set up a few variables and Wordsmith
will generate multiple alternative
scripts for example you can write
chatbot scripts for responding to
various complex customer requests
now comes the most interesting and the
last topic of our session the average
salary of a copywriter several factors
determine the income a person can expect
including experience the size of your
company your location and your industry
copywriters are the brain behind
advertisements explaining what the
product does and why people should buy
it they are also responsible for
shipping the Brand's identity and tone
of voice copywriters are a valuable
resources for businesses as they are
responsible for writing the first
impression customers get of a company a
copywriters earns approximately 3 lakh
64 000 per annum in India and in the US
he she can earn roughly 53 000 and when
it comes to a senior copywriter the
average salary in India is 5 lakh 86 000
per annum and in the US is she can
roughly earn 78 000 per year
so with this we have come to the end of
the session on copywriting I hope the
session was informative and exciting in
case you have questions about any of the
topics covered in the session or if you
need resources used in this session then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
practitioners will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time this is tusha from the
simply learn team signing off thank you
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here